Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Nice!
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, moin Leute.
Windows Update ist kaputt.
Grip.
Kann man systemlich updäten.
Die Neid!
Ich mache gleich die Desktop-Übertragung an, wenn ich den Reste gestartet habe.
Ich hab den Fehler gemacht, weil ich dachte, das liegt daran, dass ich zu wenig Speicherplatz
hab.
Hab ich meine ganzen VMs von der SSD jetzt rübergeschoben auf meine Platte.
Ich hab ja noch für größere Daten hab ich ja noch so eine 6TB WD, hast du nicht gesehen,
Platte dran.
Und seit ich die VM auf die Platte geschoben hab, ist die VM übelst lahme.
Das startet überhaupt nicht mehr richtig.
Was ist das?
Ist ja abartig.
Du brauchst das unbedingt wieder zurückschieben.
Das hältst du ja im Kopf nicht aus.
Und außerdem mach ich grad einen Backup im Hintergrund von den anderen Accounts.
Also sprich im Hintergrund läuft jetzt, also erstens läuft der ganze Kram von der VM und
das Zeug von der Magnetplatte und ich mach noch Backup im Hintergrund.
Ich hoffe der Stream ruckelt nicht.
Warum machst du immer alles kaputt, ja das musst du Microsoft fragen.
Alter ist das langsam von der Platte die VM.
Was ist das denn, das ist doch nicht normal.
Du kannst die Windows Update Fehleranalyse ausführen, ich hab mir dieses komische Tool
von Microsoft runtergeladen zum Updaten und der läuft alles durch und am Ende sagt er
mir irgendwie ein Fehler ist aufgetreten, hier 0x0c19 da das gleiche.
Der Bot funktioniert, er hat mal einen Stream gepostet im Discord, ja im Discord brauchst
du euch beiden und wer noch geiler drin ist, ich war mal kurz Desktop Übertragung an,
da sind wir, iQuality GIF oder wie die coolen Leute sagen GIFs, MonkaSmoke, ich so Musik
Klatsch, das passt gut, es ist mega langsam alles in der VM, starten wir das jetzt, 100%
huge langsam, man braucht überhaupt so viel CPU wahrscheinlich weil es wartet ohne Ende,
die Windows Logik muss man auch mal verstehen, die Lautstärke ist von Stream zu Stream unterschiedlich,
wobei die Lautstärke an sich von mir Musik wieder ok ist, man versteht es nicht, man
versteht es, dafür sind die Audio Board Dinge jetzt viel zu laut, Windows Logik, ich glaube
Microsoft versteht ja selbst auch nicht mal genau was sie da treiben, jetzt ist die Lautstärke
ok, jetzt passt wieder, was auch immer man weiß nicht genau, so es ist Pepega Board
gestartet, darf ich starten, auch wenn die VM auf der Magnetplatte liegt, geht das noch
irgendwann, es ist ein riesen Unterschied, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, das ist ja keine
10 Jahre alte Platte, das ist eine WD Red 6TB, also es gibt durchaus langsamere Festplatten,
aber der Unterschied ist einfach so krass, VM auf Platte kommt dir vor wie 1995, VM auf
SD kommt dir vor wie 2019, also es ist wirklich lächerlich, und jetzt startet es noch nicht
mal oder was, oder habe ich eine andere IP, kann das sein, habe ich eine andere IP, ah
ich habe eine andere IP, easy, easy as a fuck, ah Pepega Board, da haben wir es, sehr schön,
alles da, ja, ja seh Barus kann ich mal nachher ausprobieren, dass Windows allerdings Fehler
Behebungs, hast du nicht gesehen Tool auszuführen, allerdings, ich habe mir jetzt überlegt,
ich habe ja eh nur eine 5TB, ja hätte ich mal eine 5TB SSD, was habe ich gerade die
größte SSD, die es gibt, 4TB, so halbwegs erschwinglich, was ist denn so die größte
SSD aktuell, die man sich, gibt es schon 8TB SSD, ja bestimmt nicht 153 Euro, 4TB, 4TB,
aber das erschwinglichste halbwegs, ja aber ich habe mir gedacht, es ist gar nicht so
schlimm, dass man Windows update und wahrscheinlich auch noch ein paar andere Sachen kaputt sind,
also es wird nicht nur das Windows Update kaputt sein, es wird wahrscheinlich noch
viel mehr kaputt sein, dass der Scheiß nicht update, keine Ahnung was der für Schmerzen
hat, aber ich habe mir gedacht, wir machen das einfach so, ich mache mal vollen Backup
aufs Netzlaufwerk im Hintergrund, ich hoffe das läuft noch im Hintergrund, wir können
mal kurz gucken, ob das im Hintergrund noch läuft, ich tippe mal, dass es noch läuft,
sonst wird der Microsoft Virenscanner, übrigens warum nennen die das Ding eigentlich so kacke,
da erkennt doch kein Mensch, der sich nicht irgendwie damit beschäftigt hat, warum nennen
sie das Ding nicht Windows Defender, da weiß wenigstens jeder, dass es der Virenscanner
ist, übrigens, ja und ich gehe mal davon aus, weil der im Hintergrund so rumrödel,
das Kopieren aufs Netzlaufwerk auch noch funktionieren, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, das komische
Menü ist auch huge sinnlos, ich hoffe das funktioniert noch, naja gut, zumindest habe
ich mir überlegt, wenn man Windows wahrscheinlich eh schon ziemlich im Arsch ist, hast du vielleicht
den Read Cache deaktiviert, ich habe nichts zusätzlich aktiviert oder deaktiviert, ich
weiß gar nicht, wo man das machen würde, oder meinst du jetzt systemweit, ne da habe
ich bestimmt nicht den Read Cache deaktiviert, weiß gar nicht wo ich das unter Windows machen
würde ehrlich gesagt, naja und zumindest habe ich mir überlegt, wie ist meine Festplatte
eh ein bisschen klein, ich habe aktuell das Ding drinne, also naja gut 6TB Platte ist mir
nicht so klein, aber die Systemplatte ist mir ein bisschen zu klein, ich habe hier aktuell
das Ding drinne, ich habe mir Case Modding für Lüfter gekauft damals, richtig hängen
geblieben, wo ist denn die SSD, genau das Teil hatte ich mir damals geholt, 500G, ich
habe mir gedacht, wenn doch dein Windows schon im Arsch ist und du den Scheiß eh noch installieren
musst, hol dir doch noch eine neue SSD für dein Betriebssystem, ich meine nicht, dass
ich generell zu wenig SSDs hätte, ich habe noch z.B. habe ich total komplett unbenutzt
im 2.
Rechner, da wo ich jetzt quasi meine Vorschau drauf habe, habe ich 2TB SSD noch drinne,
ja ich wurde damals für übertrieben viel Geld gekauft, eigentlich komplett sinnlos
gewesen, aber nice und ich habe mir gedacht, ich kann mir doch einfach jetzt, ich hole mir
einfach eine Terabyte NVMe SSD, das Gramm ist auch gar nicht mehr so teuer und da habe
ich ein bisschen mehr Platz, weil 500G ist schon, wenn man ein paar Steam Spiele und
so drauf hat, nicht ohne, ich meine, du hast ja heute Spiele, das ist ja die Regel, dass
man 500G brauchen und das muss ja nicht sein, dass man nur 5 Spiele Parallel installiert
haben kann, dachte ich mir so, deswegen, sagen wir mal, wie ist das eurer Ansicht nach, lohnen
sich NVMe SSDs, ich meine preisleistungsmäßig kann man sich darüber streiten, ob sich
das lohnt, aber so generell gesehen, ich meine, sie sind theoretisch schon viel schneller,
das ist die Frage, ob man wirklich was von hat, ich meine, was weiß ich, SATA ist ungefähr
Schluss bei 550MB oder so was und ich meine, die anderen haben zwar theoretisch irgendwie
3000MB die Sekunde, aber ich meine, das lohnt sich ja nur, wenn du entweder sau viel Zeugs
hin kopierst, mit großen Dateien hantierst, zum Beispiel Videoschnitt, was gerade einer
gesagt hat, im Chat, aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich relativ sinnlos und wenn man sich
mal anguckt, ich meine, was kostet eine 2TB SSD so, ich meine, das ist übertrieben,
ja gut, das ist die KUVO, die normale, keine Ahnung, 220 bis 300, irgendwie so in dem Dreh,
kostet eine 2TB SSD, mich ärgert das ja schon, da ich mir damals eine 2TB SSD gekauft habe,
als die Dinger neu waren, haben die 700€ gekostet, also richtig feels, feels Batman,
feels, zu wenig Geld meine, so einmal eine NVMe, ist schonmal, was ist denn das, warum
ist die so billig, Kumpel meint, er merkt das besonders beim Kompilieren, das kann ich
mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass du, wenn du was Kompilierst, dass du da den Vorteil
von einer SATA SSD gegenüber einer NVMe SSD merkst, da geht es doch meistens darum,
dass du ganz viele kleine Dateien einlässt, wie viel RAM brauchst du privat und zum Arbeiten
hat der Provokateur gefragt, also hier drinnen habe ich 16G und auf der Arbeit habe ich glaube
auch 16G oder 32, nee ich glaube 16, ich habe sowohl hier 16G als auch auf der Arbeit 16G,
das reicht auch dicke, mehr brauchst du eigentlich aktuell nicht, nicht TLS, äh TLC, was lohnt
es sich so aktuell zu kaufen für eine, also das ist mir zu teuer, ganz ehrlich, ich habe
noch für Sachen wo ich viel speicher brauche, habe ich noch eine 6TB Platte im System, also
das brauche ich eigentlich nicht, was kosten die kleinere Variante davon, ein T, 200, ja
da könnte ich, da könnte ich mit leben, ach nee das ist die 500G, das ist die gleiche
die ich eben hatte, nee, 200, was denken die sich eigentlich mit so beknackten, mit so beknackten
Bezeichnungen, ich meine wer soll den Unterschied erkennen zwischen, Moment jetzt muss ich mal
kurz zurück gehen, ich meine ernsthaft wer soll den Unterschied erkennen zwischen MZV7E1T0BW
oder MZV7S1T0B, was ist überhaupt der Unterschied, wo ist denn überhaupt der Unterschied, V7E2,
was zum Teufel, was ist das für eine Benahmung, ah ok das eine ist EVO und das andere ist
EVO+, ok das erkennt man, aber ich meine mit diesem komischen, wo ist, ich muss ja mal
gucken wo der Unterschied ist, also MZV7, aha das ist E und das ist S, ok das ist ein Buchstabenunterschied
an dieser Stelle, daran soll man jetzt erkennen, dass die viel geiler ist, das ist nice, gut
Job Samsung, so muss er das machen, so offensichtlich, ja ganz klar, eigentlich liegt es komplett
auf der Hand, ja, was würdet ihr nehmen, falls ihr euch damit beschäftigt habt, was taugt
ihr da, also ansonsten hatte ich ja immer als relativ preisgünstige Dinger die da geholt,
haben die auch eine NVMe, na die sind schon eine ganze Ecke günstiger, da ist die Frage,
ob das wirklich so den Unterschied macht, ich meine das kostet doppelte, die Samsung
kostet doppelte, ja, womit machst du denn dein Vollback ab, damit, normalerweise, normalerweise
mache ich damit, ich überlege gerade, ob die irgendeine schöne Anleitung hatten, so
ein Quick-Start-Example, ja genau, normalerweise mache ich damit mein Backup, das sieht übelst,
was ist das da eigentlich, ach so important, das sieht übelst wir aus, aber im Prinzip
ist es eigentlich relativ einfach, du legst einmal ein Repo an und kannst dann einfach
von verschiedenen Hosts da rein die Backupen, das schöne ist da dran, das ist, sie schreiben
das glaube ich auch auf ihrer, sie schreiben das glaube ich auch auf ihrer GitHub-Seite,
also das schöne daran ist nämlich, dass beherrscht, genau, haben sie irgendwie die Vorteile drin
stehen, Main-Features, also das macht standardmäßig Compression-Lead-Application, das ist natürlich
schon mal ultra nice, weiß einer wann heute die AMD-Reviews veröffentlicht werden, ich
habe keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt, sollen die aber veröffentlicht werden, während wir
am stremsen sind, dann können wir uns das ganze mal angucken, kommt das heute, was ist
das für Ryzen 3, ah nice, oh das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken, Rützen, Rützen
Nummer 3 ist am Start, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken dann, auch wenn die offiziellen
Benchmarks raus sind, also wenn die um 15 Uhr rauskommen, gucken wir uns das an, um
15 Uhr, das sind 50 Minuten, sind wir auf jeden Fall noch am Start, genau, ja, ich sehe
es schon im Chat, also wie gesagt, Borgberger ist ultra nice, es ist ein, Max guck mal Twitter,
ok, guck mal Twitter, ach, ich brauche dafür noch nichts, ich muss euch zeige es euch mal,
wartet mal, da sieht man mal, dass die Hardware-Ratjungs, die haben, wie sagt man so schön, das Herz
am rechten Fleck sitzen, ja, aber ich muss mir eigentlich da nichts für geben, ihr könnt
euch ja noch dran erinnern, wir haben ja vor einer Weile, wir haben ja vor einer Weile
mal ein Windows Installationstool für Hardware-Rat programmiert im Stream, ich hatte ja hier
auf Twitter vorhin geschrieben, Windows kackt ab, ich brauche eine neue SSD, dann schreibt
da halt drauf, wie groß soll es dann sein, ja 8T, ja, ja, antwolle ich nachher drauf,
ich bestelle jetzt eh nicht live im Stream, ich wollte bloß mal gucken, was man sich holen
könnte, willst du den Discord eigentlich so schon öffentlich haben, ich würde die Kategorie
noch ein bisschen ändern, ja, wir sehen uns im Discord, bekommst du was von der Bombenentschärfung
in Frankfurt mit, nee, bin ich zu weit weg, ich muss mal kurz in meinen PP-Garboard gucken,
weil ich blicke gerade nicht mehr durch, weil ich habe so viel rot im Chat, dass wir die
Fragen nicht verpassen, ich lösche jetzt mal schnell die Fragen vom letzten Stream,
eh, OS habe ich beantwortet, das ist Banjaro E3-WM, was ist die geheime EA-PDF auf deinem
Desktop, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, ob ich die jetzt aufmachen soll, ich
weiß nicht, dass das noch irgendwie so ein uralt NDA ist oder sowas, ach, das ist das,
ach, das ist, ja, das ist das Bullshit-Bingo für die E3 letztes Jahr, was ist das, moving
is easy, ja, Edge deinstallieren ist noch viel easier, ach, das ist das Bullshit-Bingo für
die E3, das ja noch schief gehen kann, Bullshit-Bingo, C-Promi, ich glaube, es war so ziemlich alles
erfüllt, was es beim Bullshit-Bingo damals gab, ne, Star Wars Games, Sims gab's, Exclusive
gab, besten Fans haben sie erzählt, Battle Royale haben sie erzählt, Pay to Win wird's
nicht geben, blablabla, haben sie auch erzählt, Battlefield, das haben sie alles, ich glaube,
das schlechte Musik, die schlechteste Musik aller Zeiten auf der E3 hatten ja mal, hatten
ja Dings hier, der Flirten-Typ auf der E3, könnt ihr euch noch an den Typ erinnern,
wo ist, wo ist der Flirten-Typ, was heißt denn Flirter auf Englisch, Flut, wo ist der,
wo ist der Flirten-Typ, hier, war der hier, ey, das ist erstmal, das ist aber letztes
Jahr gewesen, ne, das ist letztes Jahr, das war so ultra-cringe, Alter, wo habe ich die
Musik an, das war so schrecklich, und das geht, ey, und das geht drei Minuten oder
so, oh, jetzt will er noch was, okay, ich kann mir das jetzt nicht nochmal ganz anhören,
ne, könnt ihr nicht einfach wieder dazu übergehen, einfach was vom Game zu zeigen,
da ist so ein Bullshit immer, ich habe dieses Jahr ja kaum E3-mäßig was geguckt, also
ich weiß, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass dieses Jahr wieder sehr viel zum Fremd-Shame
dabei war, aber ich weiß nicht, ich habe dieses Jahr kaum was geschaut, kann ich mit
Borg auch ein komplettes System-Image machen und geht auch stable auf Windows, du kannst
kein Image machen, du kannst kein Image machen, du kannst nur sagen, also das ist auf Dateiebene,
du kannst kein komplettes Image machen und restoren, das funktioniert damit nicht. Wobei together
ganz ehrlich, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob die nicht mittlerweile vielleicht sogar
support haben ok anscheinend können sie es mittlerweile ok anscheinend kannst du doch
mit trick 17 irgendwie image backups machen die frage ob man das will sei mal dahingestellt
ja mountain kann man man kann die backups machen aber du kannst normalerweise also früher konnte
das keine vollen also du konntest kein komplettes image vom system machen du konntest nur auf
datalsystem eben machen aber anscheinend anscheinend geht das mittlerweile die
Sache ist bloß es bringt ja nicht allzu viel weil du kein restore medium in dem sinn hast du
brauchst ein installiertes system zum restore oder live cd oder sowas also ich hat es bisher
immer so gemacht ich mache meinen backup hiermit wird mit meinem home folder also
mein c was ist das unter windows c doppelpunkt users max zum beispiel dass ich einfach backups
incrementellen und ab und zu mal voll und sollte mir das system wirklich verrecken dann installiere
ich halt windows schnell neu und restore mir die sachen die ich brauche was machst du überhaupt
ja eigentlich nix eigentlich eigentlich machen wir gar nix ich war gerade auch überlegen was
ich mir für eine ssd bestellen könnte vielleicht nehme ich auch das was was der hardware hat
vorgeschlagen hat war aber erstmal ich wollte mal so prinzipiell gucken was was man sich da
kaufen kann weil ja mein windows der meinung ist es ist kaputt also meinen mein windows update
ist kaputt kriegt das neue windows update nicht mehr drauf und bei der gelegenheit wollte ich
einfach mal neu installieren gut ist ja wahrscheinlich m2 wahrscheinlich ich habe jetzt schon eine m2
platte drin nvm ssd und ich dachte mir bei der gelegenheit machen wir von 500 g einfach auf
auf terabyte das bringt auf die neuen rise benchmarks bin ich echt gespannt genau ich
wollte wir konnten uns kurz die features von borg backup angucken weil das ist wirklich ein
ziemlich nice tool für backups zu machen das ist ein bisschen ich sag mal so die handhabung ist
für leute die die windows die nur windows und grafische oberflächen gewöhnt sind ein
bisschen kompliziert wir können uns ja mal kurz das video von ihnen angucken das geht das geht
nicht all zu lange wie lange geht das sechs minuten wir gucken uns immer den anfang an wie
man das macht es ist relativ es ist moment das ist aber nicht das war sich unter vollscreen
vorstelle krasse vollscreen leute
besserer vollscreen fast vollscreen
also im prinzip wir müssen es wenig angucken im prinzip ist es relativ einfach du legst
in archiv an das kann entweder lokal auf deiner kiste sein das kann auf einem gemounted windows
laufwerk sein das kann aber auch ein anderer rechner sein der was ist eigentlich mit kaboom
habe ich schon lange schon habe ich schon eine weile nichts mal von ihm gehört wobei doch das
stimmt nicht ich habe schon ich habe letztens also gar was von ihm gehört allerdings ich habe schon
eine weile nicht mit ihm gesprochen was aber nicht an ihm liegt sondern an mir weil ich ja so mit
allen sozialen dingern irgendwie weil ich schieb ja immer kommunikation mit leuten auf deswegen habe
ich schon eine weile nicht mit ihm gesprochen man kann das auch auf jedem beliebigen rechner
backappen wo man ssh zugang drauf hat und was ist was was das richtig coole daran ist es macht
standardmäßig die duplication es macht standardmäßig encryption die duplication encryption und compression
also sprich das ding komprimiert die vorbei macht es überhaupt compression ich glaube schon
wenn es ist komprimiert die dateien die du hast es ist die duplicated die also sprich das heißt
im endeffekt wobei es ist nicht es ist die duplicate macht nicht mal die duplication auf
datei ebene sondern auf block ebene das ist richtig nice mal angenommen ihr habt jetzt zehn
windows rechner die ja backappt ja und wenn ihr das theoretisch alle zehn windows rechner in das
gleiche als schief backappt dann braucht dieser ganze c doppelpunkt windows ordner und sowas so
gut wie keinen speicher mehr weil er erkennt dass die dateien schon da sind beziehungsweise dass die
blöcke gleich sind dass die schon dass die schon drinnen sind und du sparst extrem viel speicher
platz wenn du halt dateien doppelt hast oder oder wenn du teile von dateien doppelt hast reicht
das schon der macht sie auf block ebene dann komprimiert er noch das macht die ganze sache
eh schon kleiner und das beste ist dass das standardmäßig halt komplett komplett verschlüsselt
läuft das heißt man muss sich da auch gar keine gedanken machen man kann es auch theoretisch
wunderbar für engel offsite backapp verwenden wenn man dann ist wenn man da irgendwie die
möglichkeit hat sich das entweder zu mountain lokal hin das laufwerk was man hat oder eben
ssh darauf zuzugreifen und zumindest ssh geht geht eigentlich geht eigentlich bei allen sachen die
man sich so mieten kann es ist das stimmt es ist relativ schnell das mit betrieb unter windows
sage ich gleich was zu es ist relativ schnell das stimmt das ist nicht einfach nur daher gelabert
ich meine es ist zwar auf den ersten blick ist es in den peißen programm für back up aber
sie schreiben es ja auch hier dass die relativ viel was performance kritisch ist nc implementiert
haben und das merkt man das fühlt sich nicht an dass sie fühlt sich nicht langsam an gut
bla caching sonst was also die performance ist wirklich gut wenn du mal deine festplatte
gebacken hast und in die inkriminelles backup hinterher schiebt es eine sache von zwei minuten und eins
ist klar umso schneller das backup geht umso größer ist die chance dass man es macht und es
nicht sein lässt weil es bringt einem nichts also das geilste backup programm bringt einem nichts
wenn der eigentliche backup prozess nervig ist und man quasi kein bock hat backups zu machen
genau bla encryption compression oft seit bergab habe ich alles schon gesagt ja und was auch sehr
nice ist man kann seine backups mounten also sprich man kann sagen ich glaube das geht aber
nicht das geht aber noch nicht unter windows vielleicht mit wsl wobei wsl sachen mounten
ist ja auch so ein ding das geht nicht richtig das ist richtig cool man kann sich nämlich angucken
ok backup von vor sagen wir einem halben jahr und dann hast du ja oftmals das problem dass du
was restoren willst und nicht mehr so genau weißt wo das ganze ist was bundeswehr laptops
ne haben wir nix kann man gleich angucken ja und das schöne daran ist wenn man ein backup gemacht hat
vor einem halben jahr und nicht mehr so genau weiß wo wo das eigentlich ist was man sucht kann
man sich das einfach mounten also sprich man hat dann im wind man hat dann für die windows leute
um das jetzt mal ein bisschen begreiflich ausdrücken du hast dann einfach ein weiteres
laufwerk im explorer drin wo du gucken kannst unter linux ist natürlich ein bisschen anders
aber nur so dass man das was verstehen kann hast ein eigenes laufwerk drin was quasi den
zustand des systems zu diesem backup wieder spiegelt und das kannst du ganz normal durch
suchen volltext suche ganz fein drauf machen ganze krepp drauf machen alles was du brauchst
man findet die dateien relativ schnell das ist wirklich also das backup programm ist finde ich
das beste was es gibt und sowohl unter zykwin als auch unter unter diesem wsl funktioniert es
ganz gut ich habe es unter wsl laufen ich habe eigentlich keine probleme also es funktioniert
unter linux macbsd und es funktioniert auch unter windows sie schreiben zwar hier experimental no
binaries aber es funktioniert auch unter windows das einzige der einzige nachteil den man unter
windows hat ist zumindest letztes mal wo ich wo ich das geguckt wo ich mal wirklich geprüft
habe wie schnell es ist mir das war verglichen habe ist dass es unter windows lange zeit ein
bisschen langsamer war ich weiß nicht ob das noch so ist kann sein dass das überhaupt nicht
mehr nicht mehr so ist es war unter windows ein bisschen langsamer weil der auf irgendwelche
python libraries zurückgreifen musste anstatt ihre ihre zähgeschichten verwenden zu können
ok aber es war trotzdem nicht nicht langsam es ist open source ist es auf github also ich kann
euch das nur empfehlen wenn ihr ein backup programm braucht guckt euch das mal an es ist wenn man
nur windows gewohnt ist und windows ui ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig aber an sich finde
ich ist das beste backup programm was es gibt wenn man sich da ein bisschen rein gefunden hat das
ist wirklich cool so viel dazu genau jetzt wo ich mal in mein ppega board guck mal wie gesagt ganzen
sachen habe ich ja voll übersehen pdf haben wir geöffnet hatten wir das letzte mal auch discord
hatten wir auch das hatten wir das letzte mal doch alles schon wann der go stream geplant ist das
weiß ich noch nicht genau die frage nach dem os kommt oft das ist manjaro mit e3 wm hatten wir
auch schon das hardware art key tool gibt es noch eigene fitness tracker app sehr nice
kam man das protest kommt wird auch öfters gefragt kam man das programm womit ich die
ganze zeit emote einblenden unterlangen es gibt auf meinem github gibt es eine ganz ganz
fundamentäre alte version davon das neuere also also die diese variante hier die ist noch
nicht auf github und die ist auch noch überhaupt nicht fertig die funktioniert gerade mal mit ach
und krach bei mir richtig aber ansonsten kann ich da keine mehr fehlen die verzuverwenden
genau jetzt sind wir bei den fragen von heute read cache haben wir nicht ram hatte ich
beantwortet in meinem server habe ich eine nvm es das demo proxmox mit einigen films drauf ist
die start und stopp sein sind etwas besser und backups geht etwas schneller ja ok ja das kann
ich mir vorstellen also die start und stopp sein werden minimal denke ich mal besser sein backup
je nachdem was dafür falls drin wahrscheinlich ganze ecke ob es sich lohnt ist wahrscheinlich
echt so eine frage ob einem die paar prozent mehr leistung quasi 30 prozent mehr preiswert sind
was ist mit einem windows passiert ich weiß es nicht wenn er sagt ich darf nicht mal abdaten
ich habe keine ahnung woran das liegt und man findet auch nix ich habe mal gesucht hier windows
0x moment 0xc 1 0 0 2 e war das glaube ich na genau du findest
ein paar die den fehler auch haben aber du findest eigentlich keine ordentlichen keine
ordentlichen antworten drauf manche schreiben man soll fortnite und bettel ei und geduld
deinstallieren ich habe weder fortnite noch bettel ei noch sonst was drauf ich finde schon mal
ja desmond genau wir wollten ein stream machen wo wir ein bisschen go lernen ich finde es aber
eigentlich schon affig wenn das wirklich also wenn das wirklich funktionieren sollte dass fortnite
windows update irgendwie blockieren wäre schon mal komplett beknackt kann ich mir vorstellen aber
du findest eigentlich keine gescheite antwort dazu irgendeiner hat geschrieben ich soll mein in
jedem forum stand das ich soll irgendwie mein windows updates zeugs resetten aber habe ich mir
gedacht komm du hast den epic launcher drauf tommy da hast du recht vielleicht sollte vielleicht soll ich ich habe keine usb
geräte dran also außer tastatur in maus capture card abgezogen keine sticks dran nix audio abgezogen
flint nice aber hier tommy das ist eine gute idee den epic launcher werde ich mal deinstallieren und
nachher noch mal nachher noch mal update probieren vielleicht liegt es echt am epic launcher weil
ich glaube seit dem letzten update und diesem update das einzige was systemweit dazugekommen
ist großartig neu ist der epic launcher das ist eigentlich keine schlechte idee das werde ich mal
ausprobieren also wenn das daran liegt dann muss ich ein bisschen flame aufwitter aber
versuch mal den launcher zu updaten ich weiß gar nicht ob ich den hier überhaupt schon mal
gestartet habe ich blende es mal aus weiß ich gar nicht was ich dafür daten für verwendet habe
überhaupt ach nee nicht angemeldet kann man den scheiß nicht updaten oder ich deinstallier
das nachher einfach ich will die ich will den mist ich brauchte müsste eigentlich
spiele auf epic launcher zu kaufen war das besteuertes was ich gemacht habe
ja das mit go gucken wir uns an günstigste möglichkeit moment wir machen das alles ich
mache das hier über mein mein pp gar bord da kann ich nämlich weiß ich nämlich schon was
ich beantwortet habe was mit meinem winnows passiert habe ich beantwortet system image hatten wir auch
schon gesagt dass das eigentlich hauptsächlich dateiebene ist den discord machen wir noch nicht
öffentlich ich würde gern die kategorie noch ein bisschen anpassen aber wir haben jetzt den
discord der sebaro und patrick also hier the game 402 hat einen discord eingerichtet der passt
auch zu 99 prozent schon aber ich will die kategorie noch ein bisschen anders machen und ganz wichtig wir
haben auch alle möglichen emotes drin übrigens monka smoke brauchen wir noch monka smoke brauchen
wir noch als emote im discord was im epic launcher blöd ist naja dass ich noch einen fünften
launcher brauche das ist eigentlich das einzige was blöd ist prinzipiell finde ich es gut dass
es konkurrenz gibt dass die musik irgendwie unterschiedlich laut ich bin tuto an der uni
ich habe am freitag zu einer frage pock gesagt die leute haben komisch geguckt ja habe ich ja
letztens auf twitter geschrieben habe ich auch letztens auf der arbeit erzählt die pock alter
oder sowas da wurde ich auch nur unverständlich und mit voll unverständnis angeschaut
ja wie gesagt mit zirkus und wsl geht das ohne problem habe ich auch laufen bei mir
vm workstation soll unter 1903 nicht mal funktionieren da gibt es angeblich ein update für habe ich
heute morgen gesehen weil als ich nach dieser fehlermeldung hier geguckt habe heute morgen
habe ich auch ein thread gefunden wo einer gesagt hat das liegt an vm wer update macht
vm wer und vm hat vor ein paar tagen ein update rausgebracht dafür es sollte mittlerweile gehen
wenn es geupdatet hast wenn natürlich wirklich der bauer hat auch schon ein video zu reisen
köpfen rausgehauen ist den gucke ich eh gern der hat ahnung von dem was er macht hier der aua reisen
köpfen das müssen wir uns eigentlich vor uns das mal angucken uns das gleich mal angucken wie
der reisen köpft ich habe ja geschwitzt als meine sieben geköpft habe ich habe huge geschwitzt
sage ich euch ich habe da noch ein paar bilder irgendwo von köpfen köpfen wenn ich nach wenn
ich nach max fps köpfen sucht da werde ich bestimmt gleich geplack listet weiß ich ob ich
davon bilder ich habe davon bilder gepostet kann man zumindest ich leute ich habe geschwitzt ich
habe wirklich ich habe wirklich geschwitzt als ich die cpu geköpft habe also ich habe lange
nicht mehr bei hardware bastel sachen so geschwitzt wie wie als den wie den e7 hast du wirk ich
habe workstation 15 der baumi sagt ich habe mir auf auf dem best buddy pie 3 ein open vpn
eingerichtet um dann auf die next cloud erreicht um dann die next cloud erreichen zu können ja
das ist eine das ist eine gute idee so würde ich das auch machen wenn ich auf dem best buddy pie
ufw installieren und udp freigeben ist die verbindung sehr langsam sobald die ufw die
ich verwende verwende das nicht keine ahnung letztendlich ist ufw doch eigentlich bloß ein
bisschen ein bisschen frontend für ip tables oder dürfte es eigentlich nicht großartig langsam
machen aber eigentlich braucht man es nicht du leitest doch eh nur den ein port weiter wozu
wozu willst du eine firewall einschalten der e7 ist auch nicht ganz so günstig wenn man ihn
geschrottet hat ja richtig
warum habe ich in der history nichts mehr wüsste doch in meiner history noch irgendwo weil ich habe
gerade gesehen ich habe steamlabs und so alles alles zugemacht ich würde es gerade mal wieder
aufmachen login with twitch gerade mal was gucken ja übrigens danke für die follows flint maxi
from mars und guckt daimond sehr nice der emoji support haben übrigens ich habe sie übrigens
im falschen browser auf sich da gerade wenn ich das nämlich im richtigen browser aufmacht dann
habe ich auch twitch emotes und emoji support alles drin dann muss es nur im richtigen browser öffnen
dann funktioniert das ja der friseur da hat gestern oder vorgestern hat er gestreamt so
erstmal mit den fragen hinterher kommen hatten wir hatten wir günstigste möglichkeit um pf sense
oder auken sense strom sparen daheim zu treiben also das hängt ein bisschen davon ab wer das
alles benutzen soll aber ich finde prinzipiell die gemini gemini lake boards ganz gut die mit
einem pci express slot die brauchen die dinger brauchen eidl je nachdem was du da nimmst 6 6 7
watt und wenn du da einen pci express slot nimmst kannst du auch noch eine dual port oder quad port
gigabit karte rein machen wenn du ganz hardcore drauf bist kannst du auch eine 10g karte rein
machen allerdings hat das ding plus maximal zwei pci express lanes also die 10g kriegst du nicht
voll ja ich finde die gemini lake boards ganz gut für alle möglichen strom sparen und sachen
wobei haben wir habe ich öfters im stremen strom gezahlt nehmen wir mal eins mit vier kerne
kostet 70 euro oder so erholst du noch eine gebrauchte quad port netzware karte dabei und
dann ist das sehr nice dann hast du fünf port da kannst du da in also mit mit on board da kannst
du ohne probleme für den heimbereich dein open sense und pf sense drauf drauf laufen lassen
alternativ wenn es nicht unbedingt pf sense in der open sense sein muss und dann kann ich
auch eine mikrotik route empfehlen aus den mikrotik poe hex hex poe was 50 euro und hast
auch einen guten guten router der routet mit einem ordentlichen web interface und
einem schönen gui und allem bisschen komplizierter allerdings macht auch später live discord hate
was ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich ob ich überhaupt discord hier drauf hab ok das
können wir nachher machen wir schauen wir gucken uns nach dem discord zusammen an und gucken was
wir wie was einrichten wollen ok komm uns gucken uns nachher an so jetzt muss uns gleich mal den
bauer angucken der die die ryzen cpu köpft das haben wir beantwortet übrigens ich muss hier
hinten noch angeben auf fack ich hab vergessen refresh gleich null sonst refresh das soll
ja nicht fressen wo ist eine sehr interessante spa ja finde ich auch ich bin bisher noch nicht
damit warm geworden usb geräte habe ich nicht dran go ever handling reisen köpfen gucken
uns gleich an workstation 15 hatten wir also sollte mit open vpn die verbindung an sich schon gut
abgesichert sein also es macht eigentlich keinen unterschied wenn du open vpn laufen hast es macht
keinen unterschied für die open vpn verbindung ob du eine feierwoll laufen hast oder nicht weil
du musst in dieser feierwoll die open vpn verbindung freigeben das heißt ist die open
vpn verbindung nicht sicher ist sie genauso wenig sicher oder oder unsicherer weil der port muss
eh frei sein und nachdem du dich ja eh hinter du hast ja deinen raspberry wahrscheinlich hinter
deiner fritzbox stehen und du musst ja auf der fritzbox e explizit den open vpn port weiterleiten
das heißt auf dem raspberry kommt von außen ja eh nichts anderes an außer der open vpn port das
heißt eigentlich kannst du die feierwoll sparen oder du machst iptables einfach von hand ich habe
ich habe ufw noch nie verwendet keine ahnung aber so ein standard iptables regelsatz ist nicht
allzu kompliziert das ab button ja ich habe sie immer noch nicht rausgehauen den zeugs überhaupt
noch ich habe mir gestern auf auf steam habe ich mir dings gekauft aber wie heißt das park
architekt sei übelst nice aus so ein bisschen wie theme park früher oder rollercoaster taiku
ja und als ich letztes auch im streben gespielt und ich habe mir wieder bad company 2 installiert
haben wir uns noch nicht anguckt das haben wir schon wo die support ist da
also wenn du was wissen willst kannst du einfach im chat fragen ok da gucken wir uns jetzt mal an
also reisen köpfen wir wollen jetzt ja hier nicht das ohne ohne credit machen was das englische
video wir gucken uns das deutsche video an also den gucke ich generell gerne der weiß was er macht
und der hat auch zu allen möglichen abgedrehten sachen für cpu köpfen hat er videos am start also
kann ich kann ich auf jeden fall empfehlen zu gucken so schauen wir mal ich muss die musik aus machen
also reisen werden geköpft wir gucken uns erst noch mal schnell die geleakten reisen benchmarks an
also was haben was was sagen denn die geleakten reisen benchmarks macht kabu noch was das kann
ich dir nicht beantworten also aktuell sieht es eher nicht so aus und das letzte was ich von ihm
gehört habe es sieht auch nicht so aus als wird er in zukunft auf youtube noch groß was machen
aber letztendlich wissen tue ich nicht also zeig mal hier also wie gesagt das sind irgendwelche
geleakten benchmarks mal gucken ob das ganze stimmt schauen wir schauen wir uns das mal an
also überhaupt muss ich sagen ich finde es wirklich super das amd mittlerweile was aber
das vielleicht ich will das nicht runterladen ich will das einfach anzeigen ich finde es richtig
gut dass amd mittlerweile was gleichwertiges wenn nicht besseres als inter zu bieten hat
reinpreisleistungsmäßig und von kern her ist das eindeutig besser als das was inter zu bieten hat
und ich hoffe oder man sieht ja jetzt auch schon dass das dazu führt dass inter auch ein bisschen
nachlegen muss und ich würde mir ehrlich gesagt wünschen allein schon das amd mal wieder ein
bisschen reserve an kohle aufbauen kann ich würde mir eigentlich wünschen dass es mal wieder eine
zeit gibt wo es eigentlich wo es standard ist dass man für einen spiele rechner sich
eine amd cpu rein haut zuletzt war das bei zuletzt war das der fall so bei bei atlon 64 atlon xp und
sowas damals hat man überhaupt nicht diskutiert damals hat man gesagt warum soll ich mir so
dämlichen pentium 4 einbauen inter war ja damals sogar der meinung man sollte die cpu nicht
irgendwie sparsamer bauen sondern man sollte lieber einen neuen gehäuse standard einführen
dass man die cpus besser kühlen können war inter der meinung damals ja und da hat damals
wir brauchen btx gehäuse hat inter damals gesagt das ist aber schon ein bisschen her hat keine
sau gemacht haben sich alle gedacht der inter ihr könnt uns mal und das war einzig und allein weil
inter festgestellt hat ey scheiße wir können unseren kram nicht mehr kühlen das war dann so
mit eigenem eigenem kühlausgang für den für die cpu und sowas ja es hat aber keiner gemacht zu
dieser zeit haben sich die leute einfach ganz wie selbstverständlich amd cpus gekauft und sowas
fände ich mal wieder geil wenn es mal so wieder mal drei vier fünf jahre gebe wo amd einfach den
takt angibt und wo inter dann auch gezwungen ist jetzt mal ordentlich wieder wieder was was zu
machen das fände ich echt da ist okay gucken wir uns mal die geleakten benchmarks an kann ich
eigentlich das bild nicht um kann ich das bild nicht als bild öffnen
okay dann laden wir uns das bild als bild runter das geht anscheinend also wie ist das ganze so
einzuordnen der die benahmung ist wir verreisen da blick ich bei der reisen benahmung blick ich
nicht ganz durch sieben neun es gab hier irgendwie erst mal 23 und sieben neun aber es sind alles
reisen drei okay was auch immer aber ich meine guckt mal das ist schon übelst nice wenn man
sich das überlegt überlegt 3,8 gigahertz cpu mit zwölf kernen zwölf kerne hast du vor einem
jahr oder sag mal vor zwei jahren hast du bei irgendwelchen server workstation dinge gekriegt
für für vierstellige vierstellige beträge auto make sense auf allem die reisen naming alles
müssen wir uns mal angucken habe ich keine ahnung von wie die wie die entkramen das muss
man vielleicht anschauen okay hier ist die erklärung dafür dass wir reisen sieben sieben
ist enthousiast prosumer prosumer high performance mainstream okay unter mainstream gibt es gar
nichts mehr also das mainstream ist nur die einstieg einstiegssache das ist wie bei wie
die gaming hardware schon nicht unter premium anfängt mittlerweile okay und neun neun ist
dann wahrscheinlich also wenn also wenn sieben schon enthousiast ist ist neun dann wahrscheinlich
bro mit b generation das habe ich schon gecheckt weil der neue hat hat drei hier hinten sieben
performance level ist es noch mal das gleiche ah das ist noch mal das gleiche also das vorne
und jetzt die zweite stelle ist schon mal doppelt okay model number lief options for speed
power suffix high performance okay also wirklich interessant ist eigentlich doch nur ob es
was was hinter reisen dahinter steht so richtig oder also also richtig interessant ist eigentlich
erst mal nur das das segment und dann was die jeweilige cpu halt für kerne und takt hat aber interessant
ist doch eigentlich erst mal zu das vordere zu gucken wenn ich das richtig sehe okay also
gucken wir übrigens wir machen das anders wir gucken uns jetzt das video vom bauer an wie
ihr seine cpu köpft und dann schauen wir uns im 15 nur eigentlich die offiziellen benchmarks an
weil 15 nur kommen die dinger noch raus hat doch irgendjemand geschrieben reisen 15 nur
im bar go für was steht die neuen im segment ja wahrscheinlich noch eine runde noch eine
noch eine ecke höher als sieben also dann wahrscheinlich nicht enthousiast sondern sondern
workstation oder pro oder irgendwas ich glaube das dokument ist auch schon ein bisschen älter das von
2017 für skiller steht die neuen genau professionell ja wahrscheinlich ok also leute wir wollen uns
jetzt hier nicht mit fremden fremden fremden werbe video content schmücken ja also video vom bauer
der seine cpu köpft kommt uns das ganze mal an soweit wir können über die neuen reisen 3000
prozessoren reden denn die wurden heute offiziell vorgestellt das heißt es gibt jetzt nicht mehr
nur links sondern es gibt wirklich offizielle informationen und ich habe wirklich auch einiges
vorbereitet ich teste die cpus seit mittlerweile circa hört man alles oder soll schlauter machen
sieben wochen dementsprechend habe ich wirklich sehr sehr viele informationen gesammelt wir
werden in diesem video auch eine cpu köpfen und zwar haben wir hier einen reisen 5 3600
ich muss mal die bildchen verschieben den vollen weg das heißt deckel ab mit flüssigmetall tauschen
testen was wir da temperatur technisch noch rausholen können am ende des videos werden wir
übrigens diese zwei reisen 5 3600 verlosen beziehungsweise dann erzähle ich euch wie ihr
die zwei reisen 5 3600 gewinnen könnt und natürlich gewinnen informationen findet ihr unten in der
video beschreibung dieses video wird unterstützt vom i fix it pro tech toolkit im pro tech toolkit
findet ihr alles was ihr zum erfolgreichen arbeiten an pcs benötigt wie zum beispiel
easy sellout easy live würde ich auch so machen, würde ich auch so machen, weil da sind immer
viele verschiedene schrauben in unterschiedlichen größen dabei und da habt ihr auf jeden fall alle
bits im lieferumfang enthalten dazu setze ich auch noch diverse opening tools spudger und
pincetten enthalten sind eignet sich diese setter, falls ihr mal tablets oder smartphones reparieren
wollt mehr dazu finden, jetzt mal eingeworfen das ist wirklich also dieses set keine ahnung
kann ich nichts zu sagen aber es ist wirklich praktisch einen pinzettenset zu haben das ist
unglaublich praktisch man denkt immer ach so ein scheiß brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht
oder man kann im zweifelsfall auch das ding aus dem bad nehmen aber eine ordentliche in
ein ordentliches wie sagen sie auf englisch tweezerset ist auf jeden fall gut und was richtig
praktisch ist ist das ding ich glaube da geht jetzt gar nicht dabei dass es so eine reverse
reverse pinzette wie auch immer das ding heißt also sprich normalerweise ist ja bei pinzetten so
ihr müsst ja draufdrücken dass das ding festhält und da klemmt ihr also sieht für mich zumindest
so aus als wäre das so eine und das ist halt über kreuz sprich ihr müsst das ding nicht
halten dass das teil die teile hält und das ist für kleine schrauben die man irgendwie an in
dem gehäuse an was vorbei balancieren muss dass man anders an das loch für die schraube
kommt das wirklich sehr praktisch über den link in der beschreibung bevor wir mit dem köpfen
anfangen möchte ich generell ein paar fakten details mit euch besprechen über den neuen
amd reisen 3000 weil das aus meiner sicht sehr sehr wichtig ist es gibt ein paar informationen
da draußen natürlich es gab anfang des jahres schon richtig krasse liegt so die cpus können
5 gigahertz und so weiter dass es nicht der fall ist es müsste den meisten jetzt anhand
den leaks eigentlich schon klar geworden sein mich triggert es auch immer so richtig hart wenn
ich dann irgendwelche sachen online sehe die in diese richtung gehen und dann genau einmal getriggert
von cpu benchmarks reisen 3000 die werden wir bestimmt auf 5 gigahertz prügeln können und dann
ist es viel viel schneller als 9900 k und so weiter da muss ich mich dann auch mal richtig
zurückhalten dass ich dann nicht irgendwas poste weil ich dann natürlich gegen mein
nda verstoße das ist ja eigentlich habe ich vielleicht das ist aber ja so ist es normal da
fangen wir mal kurz an und zwar was mich so ein bisschen vor ein paar tagen so richtig hart
genervt hat war ein video von amd da wurde der precision bus overdrive vorgestellt also
eine verbesserung von der automatischen vertaktungs übertaktungsfunktion die namen von
diesen dingen hat immer die namen sind so geil der amd reisen 3000 das heißt die cpu
ist immer so richtig hart genervt das ist so richtig hart genervt das ist so richtig hart
genervt das ist so richtig hart genervt das ist so richtig hart genervt das ist so richtig hart
12 Phasen B450 Mainboard, euren 12 oder 16 Körner nicht vernünftig übertakten, das muss ja eigentlich jedem klar sein, aber sobald ihr einen 10, 12, 16 Phasen Board habt, macht das keinen Unterschied mehr.
Da ist es nicht so, dass dann euren CPU sich plötzlich mega krass übertakten können, weil ihr 16 oder 16 Phasen wechselt, da tut sich eigentlich nichts mehr.
Also alle guten X570...
Also hast du ein halbwegs gescheites Mainboard mit halbwegs gescheiter Spannungsversorgung, das ist eigentlich vollkommen burscht.
Da gibt es keine Unterschiede, was Precision Boost Overdrive betrifft.
Und was mich am meisten genervt hat, ist, dass dann einer von AMD dort eine Kurve zeichnet, wie sich die Frequenz verändert.
Und dann sagt er, die Frequenz kann sich zum Beispiel verändern von 4,55 auf 4,75 GHz.
In welcher Welt? Mit Flüssigstichstoff?
Wenn halt sowas gepostet wird, dann denke ich mir, warum? Warum macht man das?
Das führt doch am Ende nur zur Enttäuschung von den Kunden, weil die Taktraten kann man faktisch einfach nicht erreichen.
Das ist absolut unmöglich. Diese Taktraten können nicht erreicht werden.
Wo wir auch schon dazu kommen, was für Taktraten können wir denn von Ryzen 3000 erreichen?
Ja, die Hersteller posten aber generell ein bisschen, also die posten gerne Bullshit im Vorfeld.
Das verstehe ich. Das ist wirklich ein Thema, da könnte ich mich auch lange darüber auslassen.
Das ist bei Games genauso. Da werden übertrieben die Erwartungen geschürt.
Also sprich, du hast in einem Game irgendwas eingebaut, was vielleicht auch schon die Leute ein paar Jahre über gesagt haben.
Und es ist eigentlich nur was ganz Kleines, was ganz Kleines am Rande.
Aber dann wird dann in 15 Minuten ein super awesome, experience, grandios, Deluxe, Premium, HD, Ultra 8K Video draus gemacht.
Und am Ende kommt das Game raus und alle denken sich ja gut, wo ist es jetzt?
Ja da, da, guck mal da, so drei Sekunden lang.
Die tragen gerne, genau, Main, das beste Beispiel, Fish AI.
Fish AI, genau so eine Scheiße. Machen sie eine riesen Hype drum, ja?
Und dann kommt es raus und dann denkst du dir so, ah ja, und weiter geht es, ja.
Warten, ich habe 3600X getestet, 3600, 3800X, 3900X, 3950X.
3950X, die Informationen darf ich leider noch nicht veröffentlichen, das werden wir erst im September machen können.
Aber alle anderen CPUs landen irgendwo zwischen 4,2 und 4,3 GHz.
Endlich mal jemand mit ordentlich Lüftern.
Auf allen Kernen, da gibt es keinen Unterschied.
Es ist egal, ob eure CPU 6 Kerne hat, 8 Kerne, 12 Kerne, keinen Unterschied.
Weil am Ende steigt ja dadurch nur die Leistungsaufnahme.
Ihr habt ja einfach nur mehr Kerne, die Typen der Kerne, also die Art, die Struktur, wie die CPU gebaut ist, ist ja alles identisch.
Deswegen macht das einfach mal faktisch keinen Unterschied.
Ist das so?
Ich dachte schon, dass die Kerne auf einer CPU-Unterschiedsschiene, nennen wir es mal, Qualität haben können.
Und dass du durchaus mit einem Kern, keine Ahnung, 4,8 mit einem Kern auf 4,7 schaffen kannst.
Oder ist das da irgendwie anders?
Ich dachte schon, dass es einen Unterschied macht.
Was meint er dann?
Also dass ich da keinen Einfluss drauf habe, wenn ich es mir kauf oder was?
Ach so! Ach so! Ah!
Der meint, dass es egal ist, ob ich mir eine 6- oder 8-Kern-CPU kaufe, weil im Prinzip von AMD auf allen die gleichen Kerne verbaut werden.
Also sprich, ich kann nicht davon ausgehen, wenn ich mir eine 8-Kerne-CPU kaufe, dass ich die irgendwie weiter übertacken kann.
Ja gut, wenn es das Gleiche ist, was da drauf geätzt ist, dann ist klar.
Ja, dadurch nur die Leistungsaufnahme. Ihr habt ja einfach nur mehr Kerne. Die Typen der Kerne, also die Art, die Struktur, wie die CPU gebaut ist, ist ja alles identisch. Deswegen macht das einfach mal faktisch keinen Unterschied.
Das ist ja ähnlich wie bei einem Skylake X. Das macht auch keinen Unterschied, ob ihr einen 12-Kerner, 14-Kerner, 16-Kerner, 18-Kerner habt.
Unter 96-Kerner gibt es bei mir nichts.
Ich am Ende alle gleich übertacken. Nur die Leistungsaufnahme ist natürlich mit der wachsenden Anzahl der Kerne entsprechend steigend. Dementsprechend erwartet ihr nicht zu viel.
Die Taktraten, die ihr erwarten könnt, 4,2 bis 4,3 Gigahertz auf allen Kern.
Das ist ja dann schlecht.
Da haben wir auch sowas, was ich mit euch kurz besprechen möchte.
Ja, es ist ja nicht, als wäre das jetzt irgendwelche total vergibten Kaktraten oder so. Das ist schon nice, ja.
Also meiner aktuell habe ich, also mein i7 wohlgemerkt, der läuft...
Äh, gute Frage.
Auf was läuft der i7-Standard?
4,6 oder so, ne?
4,7. Ich glaube, dann habe ich ihn gerade auf 4,9 laufen. Oder auf 5. Ich glaube, auf 5 habe ich ihn laufen.
Wir haben ja damals einen Übertaktungs-Stream gemacht. Eigentlich können wir noch mal gucken.
Hat jetzt mit AMD-Sachen gar nicht so großartig zu tun.
Aber übrigens, das hier ist das Archiv, was der Sebaro gebastelt hat. Da sind alle, fast alle, fast alle Streams drinnen.
Da ist auch der Übertaktungs-Stream. Was haben wir dann am Ende geschafft?
Wobei, nee, das war der erste Übertaktungs-Stream. Da haben wir nicht so viel hingekriegt.
Da war ja noch ungeköpft die CPU.
Okay, nee, dann haben wir gar keinen Stream mit geköpfter CPU.
Egal, hat für die Ryzen-Dinger jetzt auch gar keine Aussagekraft, was ich damals beim i7 gemacht habe.
Core Boost ist ja zum Beispiel angegeben 3600x mit 4,4, 3800x mit 4,5, 3900x mit 4,6, 3950x mit 4,7.
Wie gesagt, 3950x lassen wir jetzt erstmal weg. Dürfen wir ja noch nichts zu sagen.
3900x, angegeben mit 4,6 GHz Boost, hat die 4,6 GHz Boost bei mir nie erreicht. In keinem einzigen Zustand.
Egal, ob das mit Custom-Vacu war, die CPU maximal 30°C.
Ich wäre ja schon froh, wenn das irgendwie ansatzweise mit Luftkühlung hinhaut.
Wasserkühlung gibt es bei mir im Rechner nicht. Also, ist nicht drinnen.
Ich habe maximal 4,5 GHz gesehen, typischerweise aber eher 4,4.
3800x, angegeben mit 4,5, habe ich nie gesehen, sondern maximal 4,45, meistens eher 4,4.
3600x, angegeben mit 4,4, die 4,4 habe ich gesehen, meistens aber eher 4,3.
Und das liegt daran, weil AMD bei den Ryzen 3000 mittlerweile den absolut maximal möglichen Takt angibt.
Bei Ryzen 2000 wurde angegeben, was die CPU auf jeden Fall schafft und das XFR hat darüber hinaus einfach nochmal 100-150 MHz geboostet, wenn es ging.
Bei Ryzen 3000 macht das XFR das nicht. Bei Ryzen 3000 ist der absolut maximale XFR-Takt angegeben, der in der Regel aber,
zumindest das, was ich testen konnte, ich habe über 10 CPUs getestet, keine einzige CPU hat einen maximal angegebenen XFR-Takt erreicht.
Was ich ein bisschen fragwürdig finde, Ryzen 2000 fand ich in der Hinsicht sympathischer, da wurde ein Takt angegeben und der Takt wurde übertroffen.
Das heißt, das ist eigentlich cool, man hat einen garantierten...
Na gut, das ist halt AMD, schreibt halt wie jeder Hersteller gerne große Zahlen drauf.
... und darüber hinaus ist halt...
Ich finde es auch beknackt.
... extra, wenn man eine bessere Kühlung hat, ein besseres Mainboard oder sowas.
Bei Ryzen 3000 ist es so, es wird einen Takt angegeben, der aber oft nicht erreicht wird und das finde ich ein bisschen...
Finde ich nicht so cool, muss ich sagen.
Werfen wir kurz einen Blick auf das sogenannte Power-Frequency-Scaling über die Temperatur.
Ich habe quasi einen Ryzen...
Ja klar, gleich erstmal, ist klar.
Ich meine, wer macht das nicht, ne? Ne neue CPU erst mal eingebaut, erst mal Stickstoff drauf, bam!
Ich hab schon hier, ich hab die Stickstoffflasche schon am Start.
... und hab den mit einem Flüssig-Stickstoff-Kühler gekühlt, hab den bei 50°, 40°, 30°, 20° und so weiter...
Aber, ganz wichtig, da müssten schon die RGB-RAM-Module daneben sein.
Man muss aber sagen, es sieht schon irgendwie cool aus, oder?
Es sieht schon irgendwie cool aus.
Ich mein, quasi das Mainboard mit dem Kühler drauf daneben, dann durch so eine Nebel durch die RGB-Beleuchtung.
... getestet in 10°C-Schritten mit Flüssig-Stickstoff.
Die Temperatur, die angegeben ist, ist die Kühlerboden-Temperatur.
Und dann hab ich immer gecheckt, wie ist die Leistungsaufnahme bei dieser Temperatur,
und welcher Takt ist maximal möglich bei dieser Temperatur und einer Spannung von 1,45V.
Also die Spannung war immer gleich, und dann hab ich einfach nur die Temperatur gesenkt.
Das ist 1,45V für Ryzen Feel, weiß das jemand?
...
Okay, Standard ist 1,2 bis 1,25.
Dann ist das relativ viel.
Aber er will ja auch testen, im Endeffekt, was maximal rauszuholen geht.
Warum sollte man da noch was anderes einstellen?
...
Also hier geht's, ey.
Alter, das frisst schon ordentlich Strom, wenn du das übertaktest, ne?
...
Geht noch, geht noch, geht noch, geht noch.
180, bam.
Aber in dem Bereich wird's ja eh keiner was machen, ne?
Die meisten Leute bewegen sich wahrscheinlich dann eher weiter unten.
Und vor allem, die meisten Leute machen's ja auch nicht mit Stickstoff.
...
Wenn wir ganz links anfangen, haben wir eine Temperatur von minus 140 Grad am Kühlerboden.
Da können wir die CPU auf 4850 MHz takten.
Dabei hat sie im Cinebench R15 eine maximale Leistungsaufnahme von 116 Watt.
Bei minus 50 Grad, also 90 Grad Wärme, sind wir schon bei 130 Watt.
Also das heißt, wir haben zusätzlich 14 Watt Leistungsaufnahme.
Und dann können wir auch nur noch auf 4600 MHz takten.
Also wir verlieren durch die 90 Grad 250 MHz möglichen Takt.
Bei 0 Grad Celsius sind wir bei 144 Watt Leistungsaufnahme und 4450 MHz.
Bei 30 Grad Celsius sind wir bei ca. 157 Watt Leistungsaufnahme, 4275 MHz.
Und da sieht man von 30 auf 50 Grad Celsius, da sind wir bei 175 Watt und 4200 MHz.
Das heißt, wir können aus diesem Diagramm ca. rausziehen, dass man durch 20 Grad heißere CPU ca. 75 bis 100 MHz verliert.
Das ist so ungefähr das Scaling, also 50 bis 100 MHz.
Gut, das wäre jetzt für mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so relevant.
Ich würde gucken, dass ich mit der Leistung zufrieden bin, die das Ding erstmal stock bringt.
Und dann würde ich gucken, was kann ich mit normaler Luftkühlung rausholen und dann ist gut.
Also das ist jetzt ja schon eher die Variante für die Extrem-Übertaktors, Leute.
Ich meine, das ist interessant zu wissen, aber ich glaube, wirklich relevant für viele wird es nicht sein.
Was eine bessere CPU bedeutet, habt ihr eine Kassenwasserkühlung, eure Kassenwasserkühlung ist ultra krass.
Hält eure CPU bei maximal 40 Grad Celsius, dann könnt ihr eure CPU wahrscheinlich 100 MHz höher takten, als wenn eure CPU mit einer All-in-One-Wasserkühlung bei 60 Grad ist.
Das ist so das, was man hier rausziehen kann.
Welche Luftkühlung hast du und warum keine All-in-One-Wasserkühlung?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe keine Wasserkühlung, weil ich, das ist jetzt eine bescheuerte Antwort, aber ich hatte noch nie eine Wasserkühlung.
Ich hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich einen Rechner gekauft habe, auch keinen Bock, mich mit Wasserkühlung zu beschäftigen.
Deswegen habe ich eine Luftkühlung. Ich habe so ziemlich den besten Lüfter damals gekauft, den es gab.
Nämlich den da.
Nicht das der alte Rechner.
Hallo.
Jaja, Max ist gut.
Nämlich den da.
Und das ist auch wirklich ein nicer Lüfter.
Das ist vor allem ein, ein huge, fetter Lüfter.
Also das Ding ist wirklich, ist wirklich massiv, ja.
Und ich war dann so bescheuert, ich habe mir sogar noch so, so Case Modding-Aufsätze gekauft in, in, in, äh, weiß und schwarz und habe davon sogar, also total beknackt.
Ähm, aber der Lüfter ist wirklich massive, äh, huge.
Enormous hier, da.
Kannst sogar zwei Lüfter dran machen, ich habe aber nur einen dran.
Also der hier sieht man es ganz gut von den größten Verhältnissen her.
Ich meine, von der Gewichtsverteilung her ist es so, dass wahrscheinlich der Lüfter das Doppelte vom Mainboard insgesamt wiegt oder sowas.
Also das ist wirklich riesen, ein riesen Teil.
Was ist denn das?
Kaffeewärmer oder was, Basis?
Kaffeetassenwärmer.
So, und zumindest das Ding ist wirklich extrem nice.
Äh, CPU-Temperaturen ist dümpelt ganz weit unten rum und wenn es hochdreht, dann dreht es nie so hoch, dass es jetzt extrem laut wird.
Und wenn es hochdreht, dann eigentlich auch nur, ähm, wenn wirklich der Sache ein bisschen was, was abverlangt wird.
Pios-Batterie.
Eine Pio, ja ist klar.
Und da sieht man auch schön, wie sich die Leistungsaufnahme verändert, wenn man flüssig Schickstoff verwendet.
Von 50 Grad auf minus 140 Grad braucht die CPU einfach mal 60 Watt weniger.
Ja, das ist schon krass.
Obwohl wir die CPU um 650 MHz übertakten.
Man kann es doch von abgesehen, dazu brauchst du aber erst mal flüssig Schickstoff, ne?
Ein sehr, sehr interessanter Zusammenhang, den es einfach nur...
Das ist ja fürs Alltägliche ist, das ist ja auch nichts.
...drei gleichbleibender Spannung.
Das sind so ein paar Basisinformationen, die ich euch erst mal zu Ryzen 3000 geben wollte.
Und jetzt fangen wir an und köpfen einfach mal den Ryzen 5 3600.
Dafür verwenden wir den Dilly Die Mate 2.
Köpfungsvorgang sollte ähnlich sein zum Ryzen 2000.
Das heißt wir werden erstmal mit einer Rasierklinge außen rumschneiden.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie das Teil, was ich...
Hatte ich das auch zum Köpfen?
Nein, ich hatte nicht dieses der Bauer Köpftool.
Ich hatte mir ein anderes gekauft, weil das der Bauer Köpftool damals nicht verfügbar war.
Einfach aus der Tatsache, weil die CPUs ja verlötet sind, das wissen wir.
Und dann werden wir erst mal den Kleber ein bisschen anlösen.
Warum will man die denn köpfen, wenn die verlötet sind?
Dass die Kraft, die wir gleich ausüben mit dem Dilly Die Mate, nicht zu groß wird.
Weil letztendlich ist die Kraft hier hinten dann an der Platine anliegend.
Und wir wollen die Kraft ein bisschen kleiner gestalten.
Deswegen schneiden wir erst mal den Kleber an, dass wir nicht so viel Kraft auf die Platine ausüben müssen.
Wir verwenden dafür das AMD Kit, das wir damals für die Ryzen 2000 APUs gemacht haben, die ja nicht verlötet waren.
Damit lassen sich aber auch Ryzen 3000 Köpfen.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal eben.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als ich meine CPU in dieses Ding eingespannt habe,
da musstest du, genau, Dr. Delid hatte ich.
Delid.
Das Ding hatte ich, genau.
Und zumindest, man spannt die CPU ein und dreht dann hier neben an der Schraube.
Und das dreht dann quasi das Teil obendrauf.
Und dreht den Heatspreader, dreht es von der CPU ab.
Und Leute, ich habe wirklich selten, ich meine, der Bauer schwitzt dabei nicht mehr,
der macht das am Tag wahrscheinlich 800 Mal oder so, der CPU Köpfen.
Was macht er wahrscheinlich im Schlaf, im Handstand und noch auf dem Klo, alles gleichzeitig.
Köpft er wahrscheinlich CPUs, das kann er schon auswendig.
Aber ich habe da echt geschwitzt bei, weil du machst die CPU da so rein und das Ding drückt dann den Heatspreader ab.
Und du denkst dir, bei jeder Umdrehung von der Schraube hoffst du, hoffentlich geht es jetzt ab.
Und wenn es dann abgeht und doofes Geräusch macht, denkst du, Scheiße, die CPU ist kaputt.
Um die Pins beim Köpfen zusätzlich zu schützen, habe ich noch ein bisschen Tesafilm direkt über die Pins geklebt.
Da kommt der Profi durch hier.
Habe ich nicht gemacht, ich habe es einfach reingehauen.
Wobei, die Intel-Dinger haben auch gar keine Pins.
Beim Köpfen bedienen wir uns der Materialermüdung von dem Indium-Load.
Das heißt, wir schieben die CPU erst mal so circa 1-2 mm in eine Richtung.
Dann holen wir die CPU wieder aus dem DL-DIMET II raus, dann seht ihr, der Heatspreader ist ein kleines bisschen verschoben.
Dann packen wir die CPU wieder rein und schieben den Heatspreader in die andere Richtung zurück.
Das Ganze wiederholen wir so oft, bis sich der Heatspreader von der CPU ablöst.
Achtung, MonkaSMOKE, angesagt jetzt.
Geköpft sehen wir ganz eindeutig, dass die CPU verlötet ist.
Wir haben einen Blick auf den etwas größeren IO-Chip, der ein bisschen mehr in der Mitte sitzt
und...
Ich erkenne ehrlich gesagt nichts.
Ich erkenne gar nichts.
Okay, da ist halt noch Rückstände drauf, ne?
... ist auch ein IO-Chip, der ein bisschen mehr in der Mitte sitzt und in der Ecke sitzt der CPU...
Interessant, interessant.
... Chip, der letztendlich bis zu 8 Kerne beinhaltet...
Ah, jetzt hat er es sauber gemacht.
... natürlich beim Ryzen 5 3000.
Alter, das...
Da muss ich schon schwitzen.
Alter, da muss ich schon schwitzen, alleine beim Zugucken.
... sehr weich und lässt sich dadurch sehr einfach mit einem scharfen Messer,
sowohl von Heatspeeder als auch von der CPU, relativ bequem entfernen.
Beim Entfernen des Indiums von der CPU ist es einfach extrem...
Übrigens, bei den Intel-CPUs war das hier, dieser Part...
Ähm...
Das war übel schwierig.
Also das nicht, sondern das, was er jetzt macht.
Das Abkratzen von diesem Kleberzeug, das war...
... saumäßig schwer.
Ich hab da eine Stunde dran rumgeruppelt.
An der CPU.
Bis es ab war.
... lässt sich dadurch sehr einfach mit einem scharfen Messer,
sowohl von Heatspeeder als auch von der CPU, relativ bequem entfernen.
Der macht es aber mit einer Rasierklinge.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die Rasierklinge auch wirklich das bessere Tun ist.
Ich hab das mit einer alten Kreditkarte probiert.
Und ein bisschen Alkohol.
Ich hab da wirklich...
... ewig dran rumgeruppelt.
Bis das funktioniert hat.
...
Beim Entfernen des Indiums von der CPU ist es einfach extrem wichtig,
dass man niemals über die Ecke der CPU-Chips fährt.
Sobald ihr mit dem Messer über die Kante des Chips geht,
könnt ihr eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass ein Stück von der Ecke abbricht.
Und da besteht dann einfach immer das enorme Risiko,
einen Teil der CPU zu beschädigen.
Aber meint er mit Ecke hier wirklich diese Ecken?
Warum ist die Chance, die CPU zu beschädigen an der Ecke größer als in der Mitte?
Weil man dann abrutscht oder was?
Oder sind die Dinger irgendwie leicht gewölbt, dass man dann reinschneidet?
Weil man an der Ecke mehr Kraft auf weniger Fläche hat?
Big Brain Chat, ich seh's schon.
Big Muffs.
Oh, da hab ich geschwitzt bei diesem Abkratzen von dem Kleber
oben eher auf dem Plastikträger.
Zum Schluss tragen wir noch ein bisschen Kontakt.
Der ganze Sweat für 5 FPS mehr?
Nee, das sind wahrscheinlich nicht mal 5 FPS.
Wahrscheinlich sind das, ähm, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich nicht mal 5 FPS.
Doch, vielleicht 5 FPS, wenn du normalerweise schon 240 hast.
Was hat er denn für ne Paste?
Die hab ich auch! Die hab ich auch!
Kontaktdonaut.
Thermal Grizzly.
Kontaktdonaut, den hab ich damals auch drauf gemacht.
Den da.
Die super günstige 0,0001 Gramm für 9€.
Nee, wie viel ist da drinne?
1 Gramm für 9€.
Also das ist huge teuer, aber das ist wirklich gut das Zeug.
Sowohl auf den IO-Chip als auch auf den CPU-Chip auf
und auch natürlich auf die Innenseite des Heatspellers.
Bringt das wirklich einen großen Unterschied?
Das verlötete zu tauschen gegen das Flüssigmetall?
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass das so ein großer Unterschied ist.
Ich mein, beim i7 war das ein großer Unterschied, weil internal Wärmeleitpaste dazwischen gepappt hat.
Das ist doch kein Flüssigmetall.
Steht aber da.
Steht überall Flüssigmetall drauf.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das genau ist.
Er macht das um die Lotqualität zu testen.
Ah, zum Vergleich.
Verstehe.
Das ist ziemlich clever.
Muss man das Flüssigmetall tauschen? Nee.
Das Einzige, wo man aufpassen muss, ist, wenn man auf die Idee kommen sollte,
direkt hier drauf den Kühler zu machen.
Das könnte man ja eigentlich machen.
Dann gibt es Probleme, wenn das Kupfer ist, wenn der Kühler eine Kupferfläche hat.
Dann reagiert das irgendwie mit dieser Wärmeleit, mit diesem Flüssigmetall nicht richtig.
Deswegen, ich würde dann einfach den Heat Spray da wieder drauf machen.
Ich muss sagen, ich gucke mir viel lieber ein Video an, wie das einer macht, als du selbst so machen,
weil das ist deutlich entspannter.
Ach, war es Kupfer, nicht Aluminium?
Ja, kann sein, dass Aluminium nicht Kupfer war.
So oft mache ich das auch nicht.
Die CPU ist mittlerweile geköpft.
Ich habe Flüssigmetall unten drauf gepackt, habe den Heat Spray da wieder drauf,
habe die Corsair All-in-One-Wasser-Kühlung wieder montiert
und habe jetzt gerade das erste Mal ins Windows gebootet,
aber die Temperatur sieht sehr, sehr schlecht aus.
Also ich hatte vorher im Idle, habe ich mir aufgeschrieben,
ca. 32 bis 34 Grad Celsius, und ich habe jetzt im Idle 60.
Das ist ein schlechtes System.
Das heißt, ich werde die CPU jetzt nochmal abnehmen.
Was ich nämlich bereits vermutet hatte, ist,
wenn wir den Heatspray da abgenommen haben,
also wenn wir uns anschauen, wie die CPU verlötet ist,
dann ist natürlich die Lötschicht dicker.
Da ist der Abstand.
Ja, da ist der Abstand dazwischen.
Und dadurch, dass der Heatspray da so angepasst ist,
dass der auf dem Chip sitzt, während er verlötet ist,
haben wir jetzt natürlich einen relativ großen Spalt,
wo vorher mal das Lot war, ist jetzt keins mehr.
Das ist jetzt Flüssigmetall.
Flüssigmetall ist aber nicht mehr.
Flüssigmetall ist aber nicht wirklich dazu in der Lage,
einen Spalt abzufüllen, also ist nicht dafür ausgelegt.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt wahrscheinlich relativ schlechte Temperaturen,
und wir werden den Rand des Heatsprayers jetzt mal kurz abschleifen
und schauen, ob wir dann bessere Temperaturen erreichen.
Ich wusste jetzt schon mal einen Kommentar unter das Video posten,
falls ich irgendwo eingeloggt bin.
Jetzt sieht das Ganze besser aus.
Also ich habe alles wieder montiert, alles wieder gestartet.
Wir haben jetzt im Idle ca. wieder 32 Grad Celsius,
also ist in der Hinsicht alles gut, ist alles wie vorher.
Idle Temperatur habe ich auch nicht erwartet, dass die sich verändert.
Ich habe die CPU übertaktet, 4,25 GHz bei 1,45 Volt,
was wirklich schon relativ viel ist.
Abgeschleift sort.
Normalerweise so 1,35 bis 1,4 Volt.
Weil darüber hinaus, also bei der CPU ist es so,
man kommt von 4,225 auf 4,25, also 25 MHz holt man mehr raus.
Durch die zusätzlichen 50 mV, das habe ich gemacht,
einfach um die CPU am absoluten Maximum zu halten,
also das ist quasi Worst-Case-Szenario.
Prime95 ohne AVX, 12K FFT-Größe, was auch zu einer relativ hohen Abwärme führt.
Wir haben eine Leistungsaufnahme von ca. 117 bis 120 Watt Unterlast für den 6-Kanner.
Leistungsaufnahme ist übrigens von den Ryzen 3000.
Das ist schon echt gut, muss man sagen.
Leistungsaufnahme, wir machen auch nochmal ein extra Video zur Leistungsaufnahme im Eidl,
weil da habe ich im Ostsee ein paar richtig krasse Sachen angeschaut,
das würde das Video sprengen, aber Leistungsaufnahme ist absolut beeindruckend.
Aber um jetzt zurückzukommen auf die Testergebnisse,
vor dem Köpfen, ich habe die Temperatur ermittelt,
ich habe erstmal 10 Minuten Prime95 laufen lassen,
damit das System schön warm ist.
Und dann habe ich für die nächsten 10 Minuten die durchschnittliche Kerntemperatur ermittelt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt jetzt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie warm das Teil wird.
...dass wir die Durchschnittstemperatur haben, das ist ein bisschen aussagekräftiger.
Da hatten wir eine Durchschnittstemperatur von 92,4 Grad Celsius.
Das ist wirklich sehr schön warm, das muss man schon sagen.
Moment, ähm...
...der hatte 92 Grad nach 10 Minuten Prime95.
Das ist schon verdammt warm.
Wenn ich überlege, ich habe hier eine 280er All-in-One-Wasserkühlung,
die ist es auch nicht gerade schlecht.
Nach dem Köpfen hatten wir eine Durchschnittstemperatur von 88,2 Grad Celsius.
Das heißt, wir haben einen Temperaturvorteil von 4,2 Grad Celsius.
Das ist nicht viel.
Das ist wirklich nicht viel.
Das ist so wenig, dass ich sage, lasst es.
Lasst es auf jeden Fall bleiben.
Durch die 4,2 Grad, die wir im Prime95 herausholen...
Das sehe ich auch so in dem Fall.
Klingt überzeugend, oder?
Also das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht.
Darum zu basteln, würde ich es einfach so lassen.
Man kann nicht mehr dadurch machen.
Die CPU lässt sich dadurch wahrscheinlich nicht mal 10 MHz höher takten.
Das haben wir ja vorher durch das Frequency Temperature Scaling,
da haben wir uns angeschaut, was wir erwarten können.
Wir wissen, wir brauchen schon so 20 Grad Celsius für 50 MHz.
Das ist sich lohnt.
Hätten wir 20 Grad weniger, würde ich sagen, okay, kann man machen.
Natürlich, 50 MHz, vielleicht sogar 100 MHz kann man dadurch rausholen.
4 Grad, vor allem 4 Grad Prime95 im schlimmsten Fall.
Das heißt, im Gaming Betrieb sind es wahrscheinlich 2-3 Grad.
Der hat ja auch gesagt, oder?
Prime mit AVX, Instructions und alles.
Das hat ja mit dem normalen Belastung, die du bei einem Game hast, nicht viel zu tun.
Nicht gerade unter dem Aspekt, dass die CPU verlötet ist,
dass wir den Heatswetter an der Seite abschleifen müssen, was alles zusätzliches Risiko bedeutet.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, lasst es.
Das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall nicht.
Was ein interessanter Punkt ist bei Ryzen 3000,
was wir uns noch mal genauer anschauen müssen in Zukunft, ist eine...
Waren da noch ein paar Benchmarks drin?
Gerade beim 3600 ist es ja so, wir haben den Chip letztendlich oben in der Ecke.
Und wir wissen bei den meisten Kühlern, sei das jetzt eine All-in-One-Wasser-Kühlung,
sei das ein Custom-Wasser-Kühler, die sind alle dafür ausgelegt,
dass der Hotspot der CPU genau in der Mitte sitzt.
Alle Kühler-Designs sind heutzutage dafür ausgelegt.
Nicht dafür, dass der Chip, der heiße, in der Ecke sitzt.
Also der Chip, wo die Kerne sind, wo wirklich die Abwärme herkommt.
Und das ist natürlich eine fragliche Situation.
Da müssen wir mal schauen, ob man da was tun kann,
indem man die Kühlung entweder ein Stück nach außen...
Was? Auch wenn es Linux... Hat Linux...
Wollen wir uns danach noch das Linux-Tech-Tips-Video angucken?
...versetzt oder Direct-Die-Kühlung zum Beispiel.
Ich werde mir ein bisschen was überlegen.
Hat er noch Benchmarks? Ansonsten ist er eigentlich durch.
Wir wissen, dass das Ding ordentlich warm wird
und dass sich Köpfen nicht lohnt.
Linux-Tech-Tips, ja.
Ja, komm, ey, Alter, kannste dich mal versprechen.
Was hat denn der hier?
Die Titel, ey.
Schöne Studio hat er ja, muss man ja sagen.
Lass uns mal vorher gucken, ob wir nicht ordentliche Benchmarks finden.
Irgendwie Computer-Base oder sowas.
Mal gucken, die haben doch garantiert schon irgendwas.
Das ist die Krönung.
Ryzen ist da.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was Computer-Base dazu schreibt.
Matt9908, macht er relativ viele Linksachen?
Ich guck so gut wie gar nicht.
Okay, das ist die Krönung, ist ein großer Wurf.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Benchmarks.
Okay, was haben wir für Benchmarks?
Performance-Rating für Anwendung Multicore.
Huge.
Haben wir vielleicht noch mal WinRAR, Alter.
WinRAR in 2K19.
WinRAR.
7zip.
Gut, das sind natürlich Sachen, die lassen sich unglaublich gut multithreaden.
Also das sind Sachen, die lassen sich alle richtig gut multithreaden.
Und natürlich profitiert das auch richtig davon, mehr Kerne zu haben.
Oh.
Oh, das ist natürlich nice.
Das ist mega-Pock, Alter, guck mal.
Die Dinger sind Single-Core, so schnell wie die Intel-Dinger.
Das ist Hyper-Pock.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Was kostet er denn?
Okay, der Unterschied hier ist, was kostet ein Ryzen 7 3700X?
Das ist nicht zu kaufen.
Wird aber wahrscheinlich in dem Dreh auch so kosten, denke ich mal.
Preise, Preise.
Erste deutsche Preise aufgetaucht.
Ein Factory.
Das lohnt sich ja dann aber, oder?
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal kurz angucken.
Hardware.
CPUs.
Ich will mir eigentlich gar keinen neuen Rechner kaufen.
Aber trotzdem, mal gucken können wir.
Wo ist es denn?
Prozessoren da.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal am AMD-Desktop und Intel-Desktop, vergleichen wir das Ganze mal.
Also.
Wo sind denn?
Hier.
3700.
Suchen wir mal. 3700X.
Kostet 350 Euro.
Und der, was ist der aktuelle Intel?
Das 9700K, nee.
Was ist, was ist der vergleichbare Intel-Dings davon?
8700K hab ich.
Gibt es kein 9700K?
Intel-Nahmeschema, doch.
9900K ist wahrscheinlich richtig teuer.
Ja, kostet einfach mal 100 Euro mehr.
150 Euro mehr.
Dafür aber auch nur 7% schneller, ja.
Also, nichtsdestotrotz, man kann ungefähr sagen, ich kann es ja direkt vergleichen.
Ich hab ja ein 8700K.
Also man muss dazu sagen,
die neuen Ryzen-Dinger sind Single-Core-Performance.
Und das ist ja das, wo Single-Core und 1, 2, 3-Core-Performance, ja,
das, wo es beim Spielen auch mit drauf ankommt.
Und ich mein, mein 8700K ist schon brutal schnell in Games.
Wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, dass mittlerweile das AMD geschafft hat, da gleichzuziehen in der Richtung,
plus das AMD halt jetzt ordentlich mehr Kerne hat.
Wie ist denn das so? Was hat denn der 9000?
Was hat denn der hier für Kerne? Der hat 8.
Die hatte 12, ne? Ach nee, hat auch 8.
Ja, gut. Okay, dann ist es nicht ganz so wild.
Dann ist es allerdings, na, was heißt nicht ganz so wild?
Es ist 150 Euro günstiger.
Und ist fast gleich schnell. Und wenn wir mal gucken,
Multi-Core müsste natürlich das Ganze noch ein bisschen besser dastehen.
Also man kriegt, man kriegt mit dem,
man kriegt quasi für 150 Euro weniger
ähnliche Performance wie in 9900K.
Das ist ziemlich gut.
Und was ist im, was ist im 3900X drinne?
Oder war das das Ding, was es noch nicht gibt?
Gucken wir mal, ob es ein...
Was kostet denn ein 3900X?
Die gibt es noch nicht, ne?
Hab ich mich verguckt?
Ach nice, okay.
Okay, der ist 100 Euro teurer
als das Intel-Teil.
Wobei nicht ganz.
50 Euro teurer als das Intel-Teil.
Und das ist was, wo ich sagen würde, da würde ich mich
wirklich dazu hinreisen lassen, ne?
Da würde ich mich echt dazu hinreisen lassen, das Ding zu kaufen.
Mein 12 Kerne ist schon mal ein Wort, ja.
Ich muss noch mal auf Geizhals gucken.
490.
Bei was? Bei Equipa.
Aber Alternate, Alternate kann man trauen.
Equipa habe ich schon nie was von gehört.
Also wenn das Ding wirklich 129 kostet, zu ungefähr,
günstigste 9900K.
Jetzt sind doch alle ohne Lüfter jetzt.
Okay, 480.
480 zu 530, 50 Euro, okay?
50 Euro Unterschied.
Da würde ich mich wirklich hinreisen lassen zu einem 3900X.
Da würde ich mich echt zu hinreisen lassen, Leute.
Zumindest, wenn man sich die Benchmark so anguckt,
ist AMD alles andere als, ne, das muss ich anders sagen,
alles andere als nur konkurrenzfähig.
Wenn das so weitergeht, rennen die Intel weg.
Das ist, das ist Massive, das ist richtig nice.
Ich meine, man kriegt, man kriegt einfach mal 4 Kerne mehr.
Ne, Moment, wie viel Kerne kriegt man mehr?
4 Kerne, doch, 4 Kerne kriegt man mehr.
Also, da kann man sich nicht beschweren für 50 Euro.
Ja, 8 Threads.
Ja, der Hyper Threading juckt, der kann nicht so viel.
Einfach auf die Kerne gucken.
Also, zudem würde ich, also wenn ich jetzt einen neuen Rechner kaufen würde,
was ich nicht mache, weil mein Rechner ist immer noch mit das Schnellste,
das ist eigentlich voll lächerlich, wenn man sich das mal überlegt, ne?
Den Rechner habe ich wann gekauft?
Das ist schon, das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Guck mal, den Rechner habe ich gekauft, 21. Oktober 2019.
Das ist eigentlich lächerlich mittlerweile.
Das Ding ist fast zwei Jahre alt, der Rechner, fast zwei Jahre alt.
Und wenn ich in die Benchmarks gucke, ist meine CPU immer noch ganz oben.
Zwei Jahre.
The fuck?
Und hier ist der, wo, wo krebst du hier rum, der 8700K?
Da, ah ok.
Na gut, Multi-Threading kann er natürlich gegen den Ryzen nicht mithalten.
Ich meine, meine CPU hat sechs Kerne, der Ryzen hat zwölf Kerne.
Allerdings profitieren Games jetzt eigentlich so unglaublich davon,
ob ich sechs oder zwölf Kerne habe.
Aber das ist, das ist schon, das ist eine Hausnummer, was AMD veranstaltet an der Stelle.
Was, was hat's mit dem Windows Update Titel auf sich?
Ja, mein Windows Update, also meine Windows Installation ist im Arsch.
Ich kann nicht mehr updaten.
Und egal was ich mache, ich kriege auch keine neuen Sachen mehr drauf.
Dementsprechend werde ich den Gram morgen mal neu installieren, mit neuer SSD drunter.
Aber es geht mir Musik ab, ey.
Also, so, lass mal weiter, lass mal weiter hier gucken.
Also Benchmarkergebnisse, Multi-Core Benchmarks,
wundert mich nicht, dass die so gut sind.
Ich meine, das Ding hat zwölf Kerne.
Was soll, also wenn, wenn eine zwölf Kern CPU keine, keine guten Ergebnisse bei einem Multi-Threading Benchmark hat, was dann?
Aber die Performance, ich finde es extrem nice, ich finde es wirklich extrem nice,
dass AMD das geschafft hat, jetzt gleichzuziehen mit Intel, was die Single-Core Performance angeht.
Und jetzt halt richtig punkten kann, jetzt hat eigentlich keiner mehr, so wirklich,
also mal angenommen, ich würde mir jetzt einen neuen Rechner kaufen.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gar keinen Grund mehr.
Also, muss ich anders sagen, selbst der letzte halbwegs stichhaltige Grund,
sich eine Intel-CPU zu kaufen, ist jetzt eigentlich weg.
Bisher konnte ich immer noch sagen, ja, ich kaufe mir eine Intel-CPU,
weil ich leg halt Wert auf besonders hohe Single-Core Performance.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt im Endeffekt, wenn ich mir das so anrufe, ist das vorbei.
Ich meine, man mag rechnerisch noch ein bisschen im Vorteil sein, wenn man eine Intel-CPU hat.
Ja, ich meine, ich habe meine, ich habe meine CPU auf 5 GHz überdacht,
die wird noch einen Ticken schneller sein, die wird dann eher hier oben so sein,
oder wahrscheinlich eher sogar noch ein Stückchen weiter oben, aber so wirklich,
außer man, außer man ist halt Hersteller-Fanboy, hat man jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Da ist das Angebot von AMD schlicht und ergreifend attraktiver.
Man kriegt für nicht wirklich viel mehr Geld, einfach vier Kerne mehr,
oder aber man kriegt für die gleiche Performance die Sache für 150 Euro weniger.
Da kann man, also, ja, entweder 50 Euro mehr und du kriegst 12 Kerne anstatt 8,
oder 150 Euro weniger und du kriegst die gleiche Performance mit 8 Kernen.
Das ist doch, das ist doch richtig schnell. 8 Kerne zu, der hat übrigens nur 6 Kerne, ne?
Guck mal, wohl, nicht, also das ist doch, das ist doch nice.
Also finde ich cool, das gefällt mir, was die da haben.
Intel bringt doch auch bald eine neue Generation, ja, ich hoffe es,
ich hoffe, dass die sich jetzt gegenseitig ein bisschen auf den Sack gehen und,
ich meine, für uns kann es letztendlich, also für die Leute, die den Mist kaufen,
kann es im Endeffekt nur gut sein.
Was ich mir ja wünschen würde, ich habe es schon am Anfang gesagt,
wenn es mal wirklich wieder so 3, 4 Jahre gäbe am Stück, wo AMD so das ist,
wo die Leute zugreifen bei einem Gaming-Rechner,
einfach, dass Intel auch mal sieht, ey, jetzt müssen sie richtig
und das AMD mal für die Zukunft wieder ein bisschen Kohle hat.
Der Y-Seed und Cruncher.
So, gucken wir mal ein paar Spiele, wenn es schmackt.
Ja, das stimmt, in Spielen war Intel bis jetzt immer vorne,
aber jetzt hat sich das erledigt.
Das hat sich jetzt erledigt.
Ich meine, 94 Punkte zu 98, das ist eigentlich im Prinzip kein Unterschied, ja.
Was man hier aber auch wieder schön dran sieht, ist,
dass Spiele halt einfach von vielen Kern nicht profitieren.
Ob die jetzt, was hat denn der Ryzen 5 3600?
Wahrscheinlich hat der, wie viele Kerne hat der? 8?
8 Kerne hat der Core 6 Kerne.
Ja, da sieht man, guck mal, 6 Kerne, 8 Kerne, 12 Kerne.
Kerne sind für Spiele wurscht.
Guck mal, sogar meine CPU, die 2 Jahre alt ist, ist da oben mit dabei,
hat auch nur 6 Kerne im Vergleich zu 12, der unten drunter.
Guck mal, sonst so Frametimes, das ist, ja gut, viel Unterschied.
Anno 1800.
Gut, da spielt Intel das Ganze noch ein bisschen aus, aber trotzdem.
Warum ist denn bei Spielen der 2700X schneller als der 3700X?
Das kann doch eigentlich, Taktrate vielleicht,
vielleicht die Taktrate irgendwie 100 Mhz unterschiedlich oder so.
So, was haben wir als nächstes? Assassin's Creed.
Ich bin echt begeistert, wie gut ich aufgestellt bin mit einer 2 Jahre alten CPU.
Das gab es früher, so um 2005 rum, zum Beispiel gab es das nicht.
2005, wenn ich da eine CPU hatte, die 2 Jahre alt ist,
da könnte ich froh sein, wenn ich auf Low Details spielen konnte.
Battlefield, bam, gleich auf.
Ja, Patrick, die 2 Jahre alte CPU war überhaupt nicht mehr im Benchmarkvergleich drin.
Da sieht man wieder, dass Battlefield generell von der technischen Seite
ein ziemlich gut umgesetztes Game ist, also von der Programmiertechnischen Sache unten drunter.
Das Battlefield Wax ohne Ende hat man davon außen vor.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der aktuelle Stand bei Battlefield 5 ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber Battlefield war die letzten Ausgabe schon im Game,
was sehr gut ausgeschaut hat und ziemlich gut lief.
Formel 1 juckt mich nicht, aber da ist ähnlich weit oben.
Far Cry juckt mich auch. Okay, Far Cry ist das Zeug ganz weit oben mit dabei.
Da haben wahrscheinlich Intel-Berater dabei gesessen.
Das scheint mir sehr Intel-optimist zu sein irgendwie.
Und Far Cry profitiert sogar verhältnismäßig viel von mehr Kern.
Aber insgesamt kann man sagen, AMD ist gleichauf für Spiele-Performance.
Wollen wir doch mal sagen, AMD ist ein Hauch.
Also ein ganz, ganz kleiner Hauch im Durchschnitt bei den Spieleergebnissen,
ein bisschen hinterher, aber in einem Bereich, wo es eigentlich egal ist.
Und im Hinblick dessen, was man bei AMD bekommt für das Geld,
die haben doch bestimmt noch irgendwie ihren Preis-Leistungs-Benchmark wieder,
aber was man für das Geld bekommt, ist AMD ganz weit vorne dabei.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, dass man für 50 Euro mehr einfach mal 4 Kerne mehr bekommt
im High-End-Segment, da gibt es ja echt nichts zu meckern.
Und wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, das ist jetzt die 3. Ryzen-Generation.
Die 1. Ryzen-Generation hat schon gut aufgeholt.
Die 2. hat schon fast gleichgezogen.
Die 3. Generation ist jetzt quasi gleichauf plus in Multithreading-Szenarien ganz weit vorne.
Ich will nicht wissen, da muss Intel jetzt richtig was raushauen,
dass sie dagegen halten können.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob Intel die preist. Ich habe das nicht so verfolgt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ok, das neue Metro. Was auch noch interessant sein dürfte, müssen wir mal gucken,
ob die vielleicht noch mit ein bisschen höheren Auflösungen getestet haben.
In der Regel, würde ich jetzt sagen, ist die höhere Auflösung eher gut für die CPU
und eher schlecht für die Grafikkarte. Aber müssen wir mal gucken.
Also Auflösung macht jetzt nicht so viel mehr CPU-Last, aber halt die Grafikkarte nervt es mir.
So, das neue Metro. Es ist ähnlich. Da hat Intel auch noch vorne mit dabei.
Hier ist Intel sogar relativ weit vorne mit dabei.
Also wenn ich das jetzt gemacht hätte, was ich vorhin gesagt hätte,
beim neuen Rechner einen 3900X kaufen, dann wäre ich 16% langsamer.
Ok, Resident Evil 2.
Was man aber daran richtig schön sieht, Leute, ist, wenn es ein Spiel auf die Reihe kriegt,
ordentlich so programmiert zu sein, dass es von vielen Kernen profitiert,
dann läuft AMD ein bisschen vorne weg.
Warum ist der hier schneller? Wahrscheinlich mehr Taktrate.
Wahrscheinlich ist es in dem Fall einfach so, das Ding hat ordentlich viel Kerne
und eine höhere Taktrate und der hat einfach nur mehr Kerne, sodass es halt nicht reicht.
Aber das ist gut zu sehen.
Guckt mal meine CPU.
Also guckt euch mal die Unterschiede an.
Das hier ist ordentlich. Das haben wir gesehen. Aber Far Cry ist auch das einzige.
Metro und Far Cry. Das wird aber wahrscheinlich unter anderem daran liegen,
dass die passende Intel Beratung da hatten. Ist ja nichts dagegen zu sagen.
Und dass eben die CPUs noch nicht draußen waren.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das jetzt sogar noch besser wird.
Und umso verbreiteter es wird, dass man eben mehr Kerne hat,
umso besser werden die ganzen Sachen auch darauf ausgelegt sein.
Ich meine, überlegt euch mal. Vor ein paar Jahren war es Standard
oder es ist heute immer noch Standard, dass die Leute irgendwas mit vier Kernen
oder sowas haben.
Ja, Cheat, das stimmt.
Wir können im Prinzip alle nur davon profitieren, wenn sich mehr Kerne durchsetzen.
Und vor allem muss Intel dann auch mal was vorlegen wieder.
So Ultra HD Benchmarks, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt drauf.
Das sollte jetzt vom Ranking her nicht allzu viel Unterschied machen.
Siehst du, da ist jetzt sogar noch weniger Abstand dazwischen.
Was wahrscheinlich auch daran liegt, dass die Grafikkarte deutlich mehr gefordert ist.
Was war Far Cry? War der Unterschied groß?
Guckt mal, jetzt gibt es kaum noch einen Unterschied.
Also wenn man wirklich 4K spielt, dann ist überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Aber das liegt einfach auch daran, dass bei 4K die CPU-Leistung,
also das was die CPU machen muss, nicht so extrem viel mehr ist.
Aber die Grafikkarte braucht halt ordentlich mehr.
Oder zumindest das Verhältnis ist verschoben.
Also in 4K muss die Grafikkarte viel mehr machen als auf 1080p.
Im Verhältnis, wie die CPU halt nicht so viel mehr machen muss.
Das heißt, sollte man wirklich 4K spielen, ist es gar nicht so verkehrt,
jetzt schon direkt zu sagen, ey komm, scheiß drauf, ich brauche einen Rechner, holen wir uns.
Ach ja, und wir müssen mal abwarten, was gab es noch, der 3950 oder so?
Was das dann bringt, müssen wir mal schauen.
Aber jetzt gibt es, was war noch, Metro war noch ein großer Unterschied, oder?
Metro, Metro, nichts.
Es gibt eigentlich so gut wie keinen Unterschied mehr, wenn du 4K spielst.
Und, also ich neige wirklich ganz stark dazu, wenn ich jetzt einen Rechner kaufen würde.
AMD Rechner, aber ich kaufe keinen.
Da Tommy schreibt, Multicore Rendering ist halt eine Sache, die eigentlich keine Engine hinbekommt.
Es ist technisch einfach sehr, sehr schwer.
Da hast du recht, Multi-Threading ist an sich so ein Ding,
wo es nicht einfach mit getan ist, dass du mehr Kerne im Rechner hast.
Du brauchst auch die passende Aufgabe, ich lese gleich den Rest noch vor,
man braucht auch die passende Aufgabe, die sich ordentlich Multi-Threading lässt.
Und wenn man mal schon von so was Simplem ausgeht, wie eine Schleife, die einfach nur, keine Ahnung,
plus eins rechnet oder sowas, das ist schon was, was viel trickreicher zu Multi-Threading ist,
als man auf den ersten Blick denken mag.
Und wenn du da noch so Abhängigkeiten hast, wie, dass du das Ergebnis von einem Lauf bei dem anderen brauchst,
ist natürlich mit Multi-Threading schon mal eh ein bisschen komplizierter.
Also ich kann es aus eigener Erfahrung nur sagen, wenn du Sachen wirklich ordentlich laufen lassen willst,
mit mehr, zwei Kerne, zwei Threads ist easy.
Zwei Threads ist in der Regel relativ einfach, du hast irgendwas, was im Endeffekt die Sachen anzeigt,
und du hast was, was die Arbeit macht.
Also zwei Threads halbwegs ordentlich auszulassen, das ist kein Ding.
Zwei Threads kriegt man bei allem irgendwie hin.
Drei Threads kriegst du auch noch halbwegs hin, wenn du ein bisschen IO hast.
Da machst du ein Thread, IO oder irgendwelche Netzwerkgedöns,
ein Thread ist halt für ordentlich zum Rechnen, da vielleicht noch ein zweiter dafür,
und der andere halt zum Anzeigen.
Aber alles danach stelle ich mir wirklich unglaublich schwierig vor.
Er schreibt nämlich noch, die aktuellen Engines dispatchen ja ihre Background-Tasks und einen Main-Thread,
und er zeigt dann alles an und macht die CPU-Instructions.
Sobald man Chunking fürs Multicore-Rendering hinbekommt, ist so was ein neues Rad zu erfinden.
Ich kenne mich da in HD-Rendering-Sachen leider nicht gut genug aus.
Das ist nicht ein Gebiet, wo ich Sachen entwickle.
Aber ich kann es mir gut vorstellen, wie gesagt, man sieht es ja auch bei anderen Problemstellungen,
wie schwierig das ist, das ordentlich Multithreader hinzukriegen.
Kommt ein Chat-Tool auch auf GitHub? Ja, das kann ich pushen.
Und was bei Multithreading immer noch dabei kommt, die Aufgaben, also die Probleme, die man hat,
oder das, was man berechnen muss im Endeffekt, es ist eine Sache, die Multithreaded durchzuführen.
Das ist noch gar nicht das Problem.
Problematisch wird es dann, also ich kann ohne Probleme einfach 50 Aufgaben starten, Multithreaded,
so nach dem Motto, hey, rechne mal, die Sache ist dann am Schluss.
Was mache ich mit den Ergebnissen?
Und in welcher Reihenfolge brauche ich die Ergebnisse?
Und je nachdem, wie das eben bei der jeweiligen Anwendung ist, bringt mir das überhaupt nichts,
wenn ich super Multithreade.
Zum Beispiel, denkt euch mal, es ist das Naheliegendste, was mir einfällt, warum es manchmal schwierig ist,
denkt euch mal, ihr habt eine Audio-Anwendung, so irgendwie einen SIP-Client oder Skype oder Discord
oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ihr habt keinen Einfluss drauf, so direkt, in welcher Reihenfolge die Pakete bei euch ankommen.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass, wenn ihr Sprachdaten übertragt, dass manche Sachen früher ankommen
und manche später.
Und wenn die Sachen, die früher ankommen, da musst du halt überlegen, wie lange bufferst du
und wie lange wartest du, weil wenn du zu lange wartest, dann spürt halt der User Verzögerung.
Und wenn du jetzt schon angefangen hast, quasi was abzuspielen und dann bekommst du ein Paket,
wo die Daten drin sind, die du eigentlich vorher gebraucht hättest,
das bringt dir ja alles gar nichts.
Also sprich, das Super Multi-Swedding ist es ähnlich.
Es ist gar nicht so schwierig, einfach vielmöglich parallel rechnen zu lassen.
Der Knackpunkt ist eigentlich, wie willst du die Ergebnisse verwerten, die du dann bekommst.
Aber man sieht schon hier in den Benchmarks, umso höher die Auflösung ist,
umso wenig Unterschied macht das Ganze.
Ich bin ja Fan von niedrigen Details in Spielen und viel FPS.
Also ich bin niemand, der in 4K spielt.
Ich spiele lieber in 1080p mit niedrigen Details und 300 FPS, als in 4K mit 50 FPS.
Wie wäre es mit viel Details und viel FPS?
Ne, bin ich auch kein Fan von, weil in vielen Spielen bedeutet viel Details sowas wie
Plör auf manchen Objekten oder mehr Büsche, als es sein müsste.
Natürlich reden wir hier hauptsächlich von irgendwelchen Multiplayer-Spielen.
Also wenn man jetzt sowas spielt wie zum Beispiel Crysis oder so ein Singleplayer-Spiel,
da schalte ich natürlich auch manchmal volle Pulle hoch, weil ich kann es zum Glück
mit der 1080 Ti und dem 8700K kann ich das ja machen.
Aber ich komme selbst bei Singleplayer-Spielen relativ schnell wieder drauf zurück,
die Details runterzustellen, weil ich einfach lieber 100 FPS habe anstatt 40 oder 50
mit besseren Details.
Das ist einfach so eine Geschmackssache.
Leistungsaufnahme, Temperatur und Effizienz, da bin ich jetzt auch mal gespannt.
Ach Moment, ach doch, das ist schon ganz schön viel.
Ach Moment, komplettes System, das ist nicht nur die CPU, was haben die denn in ihrem System drinne?
Wie viel braucht denn die CPU, komplettes System, was ist denn?
Braucht denn die CPU selbst?
Schiemaske, nein Schiemask.
Wenn du einfach ein bisschen mit rumbasteln willst, nimmst du eine ESP32 NodeMCU,
der ist super zum rumbasteln, hat alles was du brauchst.
Aber sagen wir mal, 55 Watt Eidl ist schon eine Hausnummer.
Aber sie schreiben es ja auch hier, das liegt hauptsächlich an dem Mainboard.
Ich meine, es ist wirklich eine Hausnummer.
Wenn ich überlege, die von Intel, die neuen Atom-Dinger, diese Jiminy-Lake-Dinger,
die haben auch vier Kerne.
Allerdings, also die vier Kerne davon sind nicht mit den vier Kernen hier irgendwie zu vergleichen.
Aber die haben auch vier Kerne und haben 6-7 Watt Eidl.
Ohne Grafikkarte, ohne alles, ja nur mit Onboard-Zeugs.
Also ich finde, 55 Watt Eidl relativ happig.
Aber es ist im Prinzip bei allen Systemen so ähnlich.
Aber bei mir sind es bloß 43.
Generell finde ich, aber man müsste sich mal schauen, wie viel die CPU davon wirklich ausmacht.
Weil hier haben sie es ja mit dem kompletten System.
Müssen wir mal gucken, was wir da finden.
Gut, Leistungsaufnahme unter Last, das ist eigentlich, brauche halt was es braucht.
Leistungsaufnahme Eidl ist eh das Interessantere.
In der Regel hast du die Dinger 90% Eidl.
Hat aber auch viel Kerne, brauche auch viel.
Ach, geht die ESL los? Oder wollte ich eigentlich gucken?
95 Ampere, na gut, bei was war das? 1,2 Volt.
Muss ja ein bisschen was sein.
Maximal CPU Power.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt nicht so interessant.
Mainboards, das muss ich mir mal in Ruhe angucken.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht so spannend denke ich.
Jetzt sind die ASUS Dinger wieder.
Overclocking.
Precision Boost Overdrive, das hatten wir ja vorhin schon.
RAM Overclocking, das ist was, was man eigentlich, was kein Mensch braucht.
Außer man möchte nervige Speicherfehler haben, lohnt sich RAM übertacken, das ist eigentlich selten.
Fazit beeindruckend, nach dem kurzen Überfliegen kann ich das unterschreiben.
WTF geht bei der ESL ab? Ich glaube die ESL mag jetzt nicht, wenn ich das im Stream aufmache.
Oh, ich muss mal gucken. Was geht bei der ESL ab? Wartet mal, ich muss mal schauen.
Was machen die da? Vor allem, warum ist es wahr Steiner?
Ok, das ist wieder der Laber Dude am Start.
Bin eine Minute zu spät, hast gerade verpasst. Wieso, was war denn?
Cringe Musik Veranstaltungen oder?
Ja, nee, das muss ich mir nicht angucken.
Drei Typen, die rappen, das ist nichts für mich.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken, das ist Fremdschämen hoch 3.
Aber was die hier schreiben können, nach der kurzen Sache, die wir uns jetzt angeschaut haben,
kann ich das unterschreiben, das ist wirklich nice, was AMD rausgehauen hat, finde ich wirklich sehr, sehr nice.
Pock, Alter, was ist das?
Sehr nice, gefällt mir gut.
Wollen wir uns doch irgendwas zu den neuen CPUs angucken, aber ich denke, so haben wir jetzt eigentlich ganz gute Übersicht.
Linus gucken wir uns jetzt nicht nochmal an, wir haben uns das jetzt schon angeschaut auf allen Seiten.
Also ich bin da wirklich überrascht von, ich finde das gut.
Und mein nächster Rechner, also sollte Intel jetzt nicht noch irgendwas richtig Krasses raushauen,
mit meinem nächster Rechner AMD-Kiste, allerdings wird es noch ein bisschen dauern,
weil es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre mein Rechner schlecht mit einer 1080 Ti und einem 8700K.
Was eigentlich mit dem Windows-Update, das da, ich kann nicht updaten, kaputt.
Ich kann gar nichts mehr machen eigentlich, also was Windows-Updates und Sachen angeht.
Auch der Update-Assistent geht nicht mehr, nix geht mehr, aber ich kann auch streamen, das kann ich.
Deswegen wird morgen neu installiert.
Das schöne in der heutigen Zeit ist allerdings, also was CPUs angeht,
dass man eben auch mit einer CPU, die 5 Jahre alt ist, nicht so hoffnungslos veraltet ist, wie das früher war.
Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an, wenn man sich mal anguckt, was für alle CPUs hier in den Benchmarks drin sind.
Was für alle CPUs hier teilen, ich nehme es zurück.
Na doch, guck mal da hier, 2600K, das ist von, nicht nur vorgestern.
Was ist denn der? Der ist uralt.
Ah, 2011, Leute, 2011.
2011.
Und jetzt überlegt euch das mal, also ich meine, klar, die Multicore-Geschichte müssen wir uns in dem Fall nicht angucken,
weil ich meine, wie viel Kerne hatte der?
Vier, also vier und dann auch eine relativ alte Architektur, versus einen Threadripper mit, was weiß ich, 16 oder so.
Da muss man sich nicht wundern, dass er dagegen abkackt.
Aber das Interessantere auch für Games, wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt,
der Unterschied ist gar nicht so riesengroß für das, dass das hier eine CPU von 2019 ist und das hier eine CPU von 2011.
Man hat acht Jahre Unterschied dazwischen und nur ungefähr 50% langsamer.
Auch nicht mal, 40, 44% langsamer.
Das ist, also man sieht, man ist auch mit einer paar Jahre alten CPU heutzutage nicht mehr hoffnungslos veraltet.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, früher war das anders, also zu Atlon, zu AMD 64, Atlon 64, Atlon XP Zeiten.
Da warste zwei Jahre mit einer CPU, da stand die noch nicht mal mehr in der Tabelle drinne.
Und heute guckst du dir das an und du hast eine CPU von 2019 mit einer CPU von 2011 drinne stehen.
Und ich gehe ja mal eher davon aus, dass sich Leute so in mittleren Bereichen bewegen.
Und wenn du da eine CPU hast, die vier, fünf Jahre alt ist, kannst du immer noch, wenn du eine ordentliche Grafikkarte hast,
kannst du immer noch ohne Probleme aktuelle Games spielen mit guter Grafik.
Muss ich das mal überlegen, ein fünf Jahre alter Rechner reicht immer noch aus.
Also die großen Sprünge gibt es halt einfach nicht mehr.
Huge.
Leute, ich muss mal auf dem zweiten Bildschirm gucken, wann CS losgeht, weil ich wollte heute noch schauen.
Wollte mir heute das Finale angucken.
Fatality vs. Liquid geht gleich los.
Die laufen gerade ein. Na gut, dann gucken wir uns jetzt noch eine Viertelstunde was an und dann gucke ich CS.
Ja, aber ich bin wirklich überrascht von dem, was AMD gemacht hat.
Also wenn ich gerade jetzt einen neuen Rechner kaufen würde, ich würde mir auf jeden Fall einen AMD kaufen und wahrscheinlich würde ich mir sogar den kaufen mit zwölf Kern.
Wie kommst du auf den Trick, denn da wir uns gerade die neuen Ryzen Benchmarks angeguckt haben, die sind sehr, sehr nice.
Und wir wissen, dass es sich nicht lohnt, eine Ryzen CPU zu köpfen.
Dann sind wir doch schon mal schlauer als vorher. Ach, mit CS?
Ja, weil ich gestern das Halbfinale geguckt habe und das war nice. Zumindest das eine.
Und ich schon lange kein CS mehr geguckt habe und das gestern eigentlich ganz spannend war. Deswegen gucke ich heute einfach noch mal das Finale.
Oh, ich gucke eigentlich nur selten CS. Ja, und außerdem, dass ich auch mal gutes Gameplay sehe. Von mir gibt es da kein gutes Gameplay mehr.
So, ich glaube, das meiste war ein Kommentar dazu zu reisen. Wie findest du den neuen Ryzen Benchmark? Ist ja extrem nice.
Discord gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an, wenn jetzt CS losgeht.
Was sagst du zum neuen Mac Pro? Weiß ich nicht. Können wir uns das nächste Mal angucken? Wo habe ich mir nichts zu angeguckt?
Ich kann mich nur noch an den Monitorstand für 1000 Euro erinnern, wo alle Apple Leute ein bisschen blöd geguckt haben.
Ich muss übrigens den Mülleimer näher dran machen, dass ich das erkenne.
Das Problem hat nicht nur ich. Ja, naja, aber es gibt keine gescheite Antwort drauf.
Was war das?
Ja, das Chat kommt oft getappt. Könnte ich eigentlich jetzt hochladen, weil es ist ja schon fertig.
Live Update Reparatur. Da gibt es nichts zu reparieren, das wird neu installiert morgen.
Kannst du ja bei Gelegenheit dann morgen kurz Linux drauf machen? Nee, das brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe meine Linux VM. Das ist das beste für alles, für Stream, für Programmieren.
Ich mache einfach alles, was ich Technik machen will. Technisches Zeug hier und für Stream, wo wir was basteln, mache ich unter Linux.
Der Rest mache ich unter Windows. Ich brauche einfach Windows für Spiele, für mein Videokram.
Ich bin zwar kein Fan von Windows, aber ich habe es mittlerweile eingesehen, dass wenn unter Linux dann noch nicht ein Wunder passiert,
ich die nächsten Jahre nicht an Windows dran vorbeikommen werde.
Hast du eigentlich einen Hardware-Controller, um dein Memboard zu steuern? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Aber ich habe einen zweiten Bildschirm, wo ich mein Memboard steuern kann. Das ist eigentlich viel besser.
Ziemlicher Fan von Windows. Ich weiß nicht, wie man Fan von Windows sein kann.
Nope. Kein Fan von Windows. Windows Fan. Geht nicht. Zumindest bei mir ist dazu abgefahren. Ich werde nie Windows Fan.
Ich finde dieses MonkaS Smoke-Emote übelst nice. Kann ich mir so richtig vorstellen, dass dem gerade die China-Steckdose abgefackelt ist.
Okay, geht CS los.
Dann mache ich nämlich aus.
Ja, okay. Leute, ich gehe jetzt eine Runde CS gucken. War heute ein bisschen kürzer. Ach Quatsch, 22. Okay, so kurz war es gar nicht.
Es war jetzt recht spontane Geschichte und wir haben auch nichts Sinnvolles gemacht.
Also was wirklich produktiv gewesen ist, haben wir heute nicht getrieben. Wir haben uns die neuen Ryzen-CPUs angeguckt und haben festgestellt, dass AMD was echt Nices am Start hat.
Wo Internet jetzt mal gucken muss, wie sie da hinterher kommen.
Den Discord gucken wir uns dann das nächste Mal zusammen an. Oder je nachdem, wie schnell das Finale vorbei ist, vielleicht stream ich heute Abend nochmal.
Wenn das CS-Finale jetzt in zwei Stunden rum ist, mache ich heute Abend nochmal streamen. Dann probieren wir das mit dem Discord aus.
Und wir sehen uns. Bis zum nächsten Mal. CU.